İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 27 Kasım 2024 Çarşamba. 43. ders günümüz. Saat 19.30. Terkem 31 oldu.
Dersimize başlıyoruz. Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Efendim, STL kapları ben kap diyorum. İlla yabancı sözcük kullanmak zorunda değilim değil mi?
STL kapları yani konteynerları konusunda çalışmaya devam ediyoruz.
Önce stut vektörü gördük. Default olarak varsayılan olarak kullandığımız aslında konteyner.
Olması always vektör. Olmazsa bazı durumlarda dek işimize yarıyor. Bir başka sequence konteyner.
String de bir sequence konteynerdı. Ama geriye 3 tane daha sequence konteynerımız kaldı.
Neler bunlar? List, Powered List ve Stood Array.
List, List standart bu şekilde söylemese de double link list veri yapısı günahıyla sevabıyla çifte bağlı liste veri yapısından bahsediyoruz dedik.
Arkadaşlar, çifte bağlı veri yapısında aslında düğümler var.
Düğümlerin içinde dedi ki iki tane pointer var.
Pointerlardan biri kendisinden sonra gelen datayı tutan düğümü gösterirken,
diğer pointer ise kendisinden önce gelen datayı tutan düğümü, nodu gösteriyor.
Ve tipik olarak çifte bağlı listede iki tane İngilizcesi ile Anchor kullanılıyor.
Yani iki tane aslında pointer.
Biri listedeki ilk düğümü gösterecek, diğeri listedeki son düğümü gösterecek.
Arkadaşlar, böylece baştan ekleme, sondan ekleme, baştan silme, sondan silme işlemleri yine constant time'da yapılacak.
Yani son düğüme erişmek constant time'da.
İlk düğüme erişmek de ama diğer düğümlere erişmek, dolayısıyla verilere erişmek linear kompleksti.
Bağlı listeler, bu açıdan kötü dedik.
Bir, bir kere cash friendly değil.
Yani ön bellek mekanizmasına çok uygun değil.
Çünkü düğümler ayrı ayrı allocate edildiği için arkadaşlar İngilizcesi de special locality sağlamıyor.
Örneğin her mallok çağrısı bellikte ayrı bir yerden storage elde edebilir değil mi?
Ve fazla bellek kullanıyor, dinamik bellek edinme ve geri verme maliyeti yüksek.
Ve düğümlerin içinde, işte çifte bağlı listede iki tane pointer var.
Ama beklenen fayda, konumunu bildiğimiz her yerden ekleme ve silme işlemlerinin constant time'da olması.
İndeksle erişim linear kompleksti dedik.
Arkadaşlar nereye geldik?
Şimdi listenin, yani list konteynerının interfeisine geldik.
List konteynerının interfeisi tipik aslında sequence konteynerların interfeisi.
Yani vektörde, deck'te gördüğümüz bazı fonksiyonlar a, bütün kaplarda olduğu için stud list'te de var.
B, sequence konteynerları ilişkin olduğu için stud list'te de var.
Ancak, ancak bazı fonksiyonlar listenin aslında nodüler, yani nodlardan, nodlar yoluyla implemente edilen bir veri yapısı olması dolayısıyla,
sevgili arkadaşlar, bazı fonksiyonlar nodlardaki pointer'lara erişerek daha düşük maliyetli işlem sağladıkları için sınıfın üye fonksiyonu.
Diğer sınıflarda bunlar için algoritmaları kullanıyoruz.
Mesela list'in kendi sort fonksiyonu var.
List'in kendi reverse fonksiyonu var.
List'in kendi unique fonksiyonu var.
Arkadaşlar, list'in kendi remove ve remove fonksiyonları var.
List'in diğer konteynerı da olmayan, diğer iki sequence konteynerı da olmayan merge fonksiyonu var.
Arkadaşlar, splice fonksiyonları var.
Splice terimini hiç duydunuz mu bilmiyorum ama göreceğiz bugün.
Bunlar hep list'e spesifik fonksiyonlar.
Sort, reverse, unique, remove, remove if, merge, splice.
Şimdi şöyle bir bakalım.
List başlık dosyasını dahil edelim.
Ve bir list nesnesi oluşturalım.
Stood list'in int açılımı myList
3, 6, 8, 1, 4, 9, 7.
Listedeki fonksiyonları önce diğer konteynerlarda yaptığımız gibi
bir resmi geçit yapalım.
Append range, range, assign, assign range, back, begin,
C and clear, CR begin, CR and,
M place, M place, back, M place, front, empty,
and erase, front, get allocator, insert, insert range,
max size, merge, operator assignment, pop back, pop front,
trip and range, push back, push front, R begin, remove, remove if,
R end, resize, reverse, size, stored, place, swap, unique.
Sequence konteynerlardaki interfase'i tekrar etmeyeceğim.
Mesela constructor'lar.
Arkadaşlar, default constructor var.
Hoppy constructor, move constructor var.
Range constructor var.
Spill constructor var.
Tıpkı vektörde olduğu gibi.
Belirli değerde n tane V ile başlatan
yine bir constructorımız var.
diğer sequence konteynerlerde olan
resize fonksiyonumuz var.
Tabi burada arkadaşlar shrink to fit gibi bir fonksiyon yok.
Index de erişim constant time'da olmadığı için
köşeli parantez operatör fonksiyonu
ya da add operator fonksiyonu yok.
Ama ilk öğe'ye erişmek için
yine front fonksiyonu.
Son öğe'ye erişmek için
yine back fonksiyonu.
Aynı interfase ile insert fonksiyonları.
Arkadaşlar, insert karşılığı
kopyalama ya da taşıma yapmayıp
doğrudan konteynerin sağladığı bellek alanında
nesneyi oluşturan
emplace fonksiyonları ve
perfect forwarding'den faydalanan
baştan eklemede constant time'da olduğu için
arkadaşlar, baştan ekleme yapan
push front fonksiyonu
baştan çıkarma yapan
ama o anlamda değil
baştan silme yapan
push front fonksiyonu
şaka yapma girişimin başarısızlıkları sonuçlandı.
Sondan ekleme yapan
push back fonksiyonu
sondan silme yapan
pop back fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
ekleme
push front'un ve push back'in
emplace karşılıkları olan
emplace front
ve emplace back fonksiyonları
gather fonksiyonlarımızdan
tabi burada bir kapasite kavramı olmadığı için
size fonksiyonu
ben sana boş değilim
diyecek my list için
ikinci başarısız girişim
arkadaşlar
empty fonksiyonu
çünkü boş değil gerçekten
şu anda konteynerımız
gördün
yine
allocator'ı get eden
arkadaşlar
get allocator fonksiyonumuz
gördüğümüz gibi
tek mili birden var
dolayısıyla
ben bunlara odaklanmak yerine
listenin kendine has
düğümlerdeki pointer'lara
erişen fonksiyonlarını anlatayım
çünkü onlar
vektörde ve deck'te
yoklar
arkadaşlar
bakın bu arada
ben geçen derslerden birinde demiştim ki
mülakatlarda sorulan çok tipik bir soru var
aynı işi bir konteyner için
a sınıfın bir üye fonksiyonu yapıyor ise
cevap a
b bir algoritmayla aynı işi yapabiliyorsak
hangisini seçeriz
sınıfın üye fonksiyonunu seçmekte fayda var
bravo Muhammed Yusuf
çünkü
sınıfın üye fonksiyonu
sınıfın
hani İngilizcesiyle
implementasyonuna
erişebiliyor
ama algoritma sadece
iteratör konumundaki nesneye erişiyor
bir algoritma
bir iteratör konumundaki nesneye
atama yapabilir
iki iteratör konumundaki
nesneleri takas edebilir
ama bir iteratör konumundaki nesneye
örneğin ne yapamaz
konteynerden silemez
onun arkadaşlar
içsel temsiline
mesela private elemanlarına
vesaire
erişemez
reverse algoritması
bir bi-directional iteratör isteyen bir algoritma
vektör için
deck için
array için
string için
reverse algoritmasını kullanıyorum
tabii ki
o en karmaşıklığında bir algoritma
fakat listin
kendi reverse fonksiyonu var
hemen
arkadaşlar
bir liste oluşturalım
bu sefer yine
daha eğlenceli olsun diye
listin string açılımı
string başlık dosyasını dahil ettim
listin
string açılımı
my list
fill
100 tane
isim
ya da 100 fazla geldi
20 tane
daha kolay
takip edelim
r field
random field fonksiyonu
ve
yine bizim
neutrality
başlık dosyamızdaki
cprint fonksiyonu
my list
son derece
basit
tek yapmanız gereken
reverse
fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
reverse fonksiyonu
listedeki öğeleri
reverse ediyor
arkadaşlar
arkadaşlar bu arada
şuna da dikkat
şimdi
genelde şöyle bir tartışma
ya da
bloglarda
şu konuda sürekli
makaleler
yazılar
blog postları
okursunuz
hangi durumda
hangi konteyner
seçilmeli
şimdi bu önemli
bir konu
tabii
ama
ben en son
söyleyeceğimi
en başta
söyleyeyim
eğer ortada
cevabı çok açık
çok net olan
bir seçim
söz konusu
değilse
ki çoğu zaman
açık ve net
vektör
seçilmeli
ama
en ufak bir
şüpheniz varsa
benim kritik
bir uygulamada
şu
ihtimalleri
göze alın
bir
profiling
arkadaşlar
gerçekten
profiling
tool'ları
bu konuda
karar vermeyi
kolaylaştırıyor
yani
teorik bilgiyle
hareket etmek
çoğu zaman
yanıltıcı
olabiliyor
çünkü
çok sayıda
faktör var
yanlış anlaşılmasın
teori yanlıştır
anlamında
söylemiyorum
ama
teorinin
doğrulanması için
tipik olarak
öğe sayısının
belirli bir eşiğe
aşması gerekiyor
yani işte
bağlı listenin
nimetlerinin
hangi noktada
olduğunu biliyoruz
ama
gidin bakalım
100 tane
streng tutan
bağlı listeyle
100 tane
streng tutan
vektörü
artık
ekleme silme
işlemlerini
farklı yerlerde
yapıyor olsanız
dahi
karşılaştırın
muhtemelen
vektör galip
gelecek
ama şimdi
öğe sayısı
arttı arttı
belirli bir noktaya
geldiğinde
artık
listenin
bu
algoritmik
karmaşıklıktan
sağladığı
avantaj
baskın çıkacak
dedim ki
bir
profiling yapın
şüphede kalıyorsanız
çünkü
çoğu zaman
profiling yaptığımız zaman
o ilk kararımızın
dışında
başka bir
karar
verebiliyoruz
iki
bir de şunu düşünün
tek bir
konteynerla
işimizi yapmak
zorunda değiliz
bazen
biraz sıra dışı
bir şekilde
o konteynerımı
seçeyim
bu konteynerımı
sorusunun cevabı
hayır
ikisi de
kalsın
işin bir kısmını
bir konteynerda
yapayım
sonra
değerleri
başka bir
konteynera
kopyalayayım
ve
onun üstünde
işlemlere
devam edeyim
bu da
bazen bir
başka seçenek
hatta daha iyi bir
seçenek
olabiliyor
arkadaşlar
evet
peki
reverse edilmiş
listeyi de
yazdıralım
ve
arkadaşlar bu arada
hem reverse edildiğini
bir görün
isterseniz sayıyı da
biraz azaltayım
tuhaf bir şekilde
olmuş
normalde
modern
C++'dan önce
standart
tekni bağlı liste
yani
singly linked list
yoktu
o dönemler
üçüncü parti
kütüphaneler
kullanılıyordu
hatta böyle
S list
gibi isimler
veriliyordu
tekni bağlı liste
sınıflarına
fakat
modern C++'la
birlikte
forward list
adıyla
bir
tekni bağlı
liste
sınıfı da
standart
konteynerlara
eklendi
zaten şimdi listten sonra
biz forward listi de
göreceğiz
ama
forward listin
kullanım miktarının
çok daha az olduğunu
söyleyebiliriz
reverse fonksiyonu böyle
hemen
diğer fonksiyonlara
geçelim
arkadaşlar
listeden
ve silmek için
yine
bizim
remove
algoritması
yerine
remove
isimli
fonksiyonumuz
var
ama yanlış
anlaşılmasın
iteratör
çifti
yani
range
parametreyle
silme yapan
eriz
yine var
iteratör
konumundaki
öğeyi silen
yine var
örneğin ben
sürekli
ilk öğeyi
silerek
isterseniz
deneyelim
while
my list
empty
liste boş
olmadığı sürece
print
ediyorum
my list
ister
arkadaşlar
off
front
fonksiyonunu
çağırın
ister
yine
insert
fonksiyonunu
çağırın
ama
insert
fonksiyonuna
konum
gideceksin
bir
insert
diyorum
erize
aynı
şey
gördüğünüz gibi
listedeki
öğeleri
silin
pop
front
yerine
pop
back
fonksiyonunu
çağırsaydım
hep son
öğeleri
silmiş
olacaktım
erase
fonksiyonuyla
belirli bir
konumdaki öğeyi
silebilirim
örneğin
son öğeyi
değil de
ondan bir
önceki öğeyi
silmek
istesem
arkadaşlar
my list
erase
prep
my list
and
virgül
iki
eksi bir
deseydim
breve bir
argümanını
gönderseydim
son öğeyi
silinecekti
işte
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
kayhan
kayahan
nagahan
güzel bir
araya
gelmişler
kayhan
kayahan
nagahan
ama
kayahan
gitti
evet
yine
örneğin
ilk öğe ve son öğe
hariç
bütün öğeleri
silmek
isteseydim
next
arkadaşlar
my list
begin
prev
my list
and
bölce
sadece
listedeki
ilk öğe
ve son öğe
kalacaktı
buradan
anlatmak
istediğim
yani
diğer
konteynerlerde
olan
rs fonksiyonları
insert fonksiyonları
burada da
var
yine
baştaki ve
sondaki
bu da tuhaf
melisalar
kalmış
Eda ve
Atakan
diğer arkadaşlarımızı
silmişiz
süper
ama
burada
değerle silme
yapan
remove
ve
unary prediketi
sağlayan
öğeleri silen
remove if
var
diğer
konteynerler için
bunlar
arkadaşlar
algoritma
ve tabi ki
lojik silme
yapıyorlar
mesela
listin
int açılımı
my list
random fill
100 tane
arkadaşlar
efendim
1 ve
değerleri
arasında
değişen
değerlere
sahip
bir
listemiz
olsun
şimdi
burada
bazı öğeleri
silmek
isteyelim
size'ını da
yazdıralım
see out
size eşittir
my list
in
size
bana tuhaf
gelen de şu
tabi
mülakatlarda
biliyorsunuz
sanki
programlama
dili
olduğundan
paumsız
algoritma
sorularında
liste
bağlı listelerle
ilgili soru
çoktur
hani
klasik
bağlı listeyi
reverse edin
şunu yapın
bunu yapın
ama
pratikte
gerçekten
bağlı listeler
o kadar
sık
kullanılmıyor
yani
üretim tarafına
bakarsak
kullanım
miktarı
bu
algoritma
sorularını
hak edecek
düzeyde değil
ama tabi
orda
sınanan
genel
algoritma
bilgisi
efendim
şimdi
my list
in
remove
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
ve örneğin
değerlerini
siliyorum
bu arada
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
yine
silinen
öve sayısı
olduğunu
söyleyelim
auto
and
my list
in
remove
necad
şunu da
yapabilir
miyim
geçen
derste
göstermiştin
burada
da
şöyle
bir
fonksiyonu
var mı
erase
efendim
my
list
efendim
arkadaşlar
evet
erase
fonksiyonuna
da
geçebilirsiniz
ama
yine
erase
fonksiyonu
zaten
özelleştirilmiş
yani
burada
iteratör
konumuyla
falan
silme
yapmıyor
dolayısıyla
ikisi de
aynı işi
yapıyor
diyebiliriz
auto
arkadaşlar
ve
tekrar
listemizi
yazdıralım
evet
3'ler
silindi
17 tane
öve silinmiş
alttakini de
görüyorsunuz
hiç
yok
hatta
size'ını da
tekrar
yazdıralım
ve bu kez
arkadaşlar
1 değerlerini
silelim
öve sayısı da
olsun
evet
size 40
en eşittir
12 tane
1 silmiş
dilen silme
yapıldığını
göstermek
için de
size'ı
tekrar
çağırdım
ve size'ın
eksi 12
değerinde
olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
bu kez
listeyi yine
strength listesi
yapalım
evet
arkadaşlar
içine
tane
isim
koyalım
ve ilk
harfiyle
son harfi
aynı olan
isimleri
silelim
auto
n
eşittir
remove
if
ama
remove if
algoritması
vektör ve
deck için
okey
ama liste
için
my list
arkadaşlar
remove if
için hiçbir şey yok
buna da
yine ne geçiyoruz
unary
predicate
geçiyoruz
string olduğu için
const
string
ref
s
stringlerin
boş olmadığını
varsayıyorum
öyle bir
kontrol yapmayacağım
arkadaşlar
return
normalde
tabii ki
onu da
kontrol etmem
gerekir ama
ben boş
olmadığını
biliyorum
return
s
front
eşit
s
back
stringinde
front
stringde
bir
sequence
container
onun da
front ve
back
fonksiyonları
var
ve
n değerini
yine yazdıralım
see out
n
eleman
silindi
çalıştıralım
yedi eleman
silinmiş
bakalım
bir tanesini
en azından
yakalayalım
utku
utku silinmiş
olmalı
ilk harfiyle
son harfi
aynı
emrecandan
sonra görüyorsunuz
muratan
var
necati o zaman
ilk harfiyle
son harfi
eşit
olmayanları
sil
tabii
o da
bir fikir
bu durumda
sadece
nisan
efe
ve
ayla
kalmış oldu
ilk harfi
ve son harfi
aynı olanlar
unique
fonksiyonu
o da
arkadaşlar
listede
üye fonksiyon
bu kez
unique'in
unery
predikat
isteyenini
silelim
iki tane
unique vardı ya
biri
i koltuğu
kullanıyor
diğeri
eşitlik
için
bizim
sağladığımız
unery
predikatı
kullanıyor
maestin
unique
fonksiyonu
ama bu sefer
tabii
iki tane
parametresi
olması lazım
eşitlik
kriterimiz
ne olsun
uzunluklarının
aynı olması
olsun
bu durumda
ardaşı köylerin
uzunlukları
aynıysa
birinciyi
bırakacak
diğerlerini
silecek
evet
23 eleman
silinmiş
ama
bakalım
ahmet
teoman
leyla
cem necmi
toyraz
ama
pakize
gitti
çünkü
ayyar da
gitti
şöyle
bakalım
hakan
hulki
gitti
uzunlukları
aynıysa
siliniyor
böylece
uzunlukları
aynı
ardışık
hiçbir
iki
öve
kalmayacak
şöyle
yazsaydık
s1
front
s2
aynı
harfle
başlayan
iki tane
isim
yan yana
kalmayacaktı
sadece
8 tane
varmış
mesela
esin
edis
silindi
perihan
pakize
silindi
uniki
de böylece
göstermiş
olduk
gelelim
diğer
fonksiyonlara
arkadaşlar
bazı
fonksiyonlar
sıralı
veri yapılarıyla
ilgili
kullanılıyor
önce
listin
sort
fonksiyonunun
bir
üye fonksiyonu
olduğunu
zaten
SDR'deki
sort
stable
algoritmalarının
bunların
random
access
teratörü
istediğini
söyleyelim
ve hemen
listin
sort
fonksiyonuna
bakalım
yine iki tane
overload var
default
overload
stu
l'si
kullanarak
küçükten
büyüğe
sıralama
yapıyor
yani
örneğin
doğrudan
my
listin
sort
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsam
küçükten
büyüğe
sıralama
yapılmış
olacak
ama
eğer
örneğin
büyükten
küçüğe
sıralama
yapmak
isteseydim
arkadaşlar
my list
greater
punksiyonunu
kullanabilirdim
yanlış
ara
yazmış
şimdi
sıralama
büyükten
küçüğe
yapılacak
ya da herhangi
bir sıralama
kriterini
yine
arkadaşlar
oluşturabilirdim
mesela
bakın
şöyle bir sıralama
kriteri
olsaydı
oto
fc
son
eşittir
arkadaşlar
const
st
struct
string
rev
s
int
sum
eşit
for
charge
c, s, sum, arpa eşit, arkadaşlar c, return sum.
Bu ne? Bu benim nested function'ım.
Bir tane daha lambda ifadesi yazayım.
const.auto fcomp eşittir, const string referans s1, const string referans s2, return, arkadaşlar,
sum.
Bakın bu çok güzel.
Lambdaların kullanımıyla ilgili çok güzel bir örnek.
Şimdi bir sentaks hatası alıp almadığımıza bakın.
return, fc sum, s1, s2.
Neden sentaks hatası var?
Çünkü lokal bir nesneyi lambda ifadesi içinde kullandım.
Dolayısıyla yine onu capture etmek zorunda mıyım?
Evet.
Yani şöyle örneğin yazabilir miyim?
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Arkadaşlar sentaks hatasının nedenini anladınız mı?
birincisi tek bir nesne kullanmam.
Evet.
Şimdi oldu.
fc sum s
küçük,
fc sum s1 küçük,
fc sum
arkadaşlar s2.
Sentaks hatası,
iki argüman göndermem.
Burada şunu söylemek istiyorum.
Şuraya noktalı virgülü koyalım.
Emirhan
Demin söylediğim buydu.
Cengiz Han zaten yakalamış.
Bravo.
Capture etmedim.
Yani bu da lambda değişkeni bir sınıf türünden nesne.
Burada kullanmam için yine ona ne yapmam gerekiyor?
Capture etmem gerekiyor.
Bravo.
Evet şimdi
Capture role çalışır mı?
Çalışır.
Kesinlikle.
Capture role çalışır.
Capture role by reference da çalışır.
Sonuçta referans yoluyla da capture edebilirim.
Arkadaşlar ama referans yoluyla capture etmek de burada
kopyalama yoluyla capture etmek arasında
arkadaşlar
fazlaca bir fark yok değil mi?
Sonuçta bu
çok light bir object.
Neyse efendim
ben böyle capture etmiş olayım.
Ve şimdi greater yerine
e-comp'u çağıralım.
Ve
tekrar
derleyip çalıştıralım.
Arkadaşlar bu arada tabii
şimdi sıralama başlangıçta tuhaf gelecek.
Ama güzel bir sıralama.
Bazı yerlerde kullanıyor.
Herç değeri gibi adeta değil mi?
İzleyin.
Eda, Naz
aslında uzunluklarına göre de sıralı değil.
Yani öyle gibi görünüyor da
evet
o süreçte
bozulabilir.
Neden?
Bakın
Eda, Naz
Kaan, Kaan
aslında karakterlerin
toplamı.
Mesela Kaan
Lale
Sadi
Taci
ama burada
atıf var.
Atif
çünkü
harf toplamı
daha yüksek olduğu için.
Evet.
Peki
devam.
Efendim
sonuçta
iki tane
sort fonksiyonumuz var.
İki tane
sort
algoritma
overload'u
olduğu gibi.
Default
argümanı almıyor.
L'si kullanıyor.
Diğeri
binary
predikatı alıyor.
Karşılaştırma
kriteri olarak
onu kullanıyor.
Şimdi önce
merge ne demek?
Bir ondan bahsedelim.
Sonra da
merge'ü
bir gösterelim.
Arkadaşlar
sıralı iki tane
veri yapısı var.
Örneğin
bu veri yapısından
birinde
2, 5, 8, 9,
öbürü
4,
6,
ve
12 olsun.
Arkadaşlar
bir şirketin
bir şirketi
satın alması
bünyesine
katması
anlamında da
kullanılan
fiil
İngilizce'de
merge değil mi?
Hatta
operasyona da
merger
diyorlar.
Şimdi
bunlar
tam biri
diğerini
alacak.
Diyelim ki
bu
diğerini
merge edecek.
Bu
diğerini
merge edince
burada
üye kalmayacak.
Bunun
üyeleri
buraya
geçecek.
Ama
sıra
bozulmayacak.
Tabii ki
bu durumda
ikisinin
aynı
sıralama
kriteriyle
sıralanmış
olması
gerekiyor.
Yani
merge
sıralı
iki
veri
yapısından
burada
kastetilen
merge
bir tanesinin
diğerini
bünyesine
katması
demek.
Ve
uygulamalarda
da
tahmin ediyor
biliyorsunuz
çok sık
yapılan
bir işlem.
Ama
unutmayın ki
ikisinin
de sıralı
olması
gerekiyor.
Yoksa
arkadaşlar
doğru çalışmayacak
ya da
tanımsız
davranış
olacak.
mesela
listin
string
açılımı
efendim
Males
Ahmet
Murat
özellikle sıralı
olmayacak.
Belgin
Emirhan
Cengiz
Han
Belgin
erkek değil
bu arada
onu değiştirelim.
Lambda
ifadesinin
konst olmasının
konumuzda
doğrudan
hiçbir ilgisi
yok.
Arkadaşlar
ben bir
derste söylemiştim
hemen
Emirhan Bey
için de
bir açıklama
yapayım.
Dedim ki
bir derste
normalde
dedim
Emirhan
burayı
dikkatli
izleyin.
Normalde
dedim
ben
üretim
için
kod yazdığımda
rasta
kod yazıyormuş
gibi yazıyorum.
Yani
sanki
default'u
konstmuş
gibi.
Dolayısıyla
nesneler
hep
konst
giyverdüyle
tanımlıyorum.
Ama
burada
sizin
dikkatinizi
dağıtmamak
için
konst
enflasyonunu
arttırmamak
için
konst
kalabalığı
yapmamak
için
ona özellikle
fazla dikkat
etmiyorum.
ama
lambda
ifadeleri
söz konusu
olduğu zaman
orada
biraz daha
kuralı
uyuyorum.
Çünkü
onun
konst
olması
dernecinin
yaptığı
optimizasyonda
biraz daha
fazla
fayda
sağlayabiliyor.
Yani
sadece
closure
objektlerin
konst
olması
değil
değeri
değişmeyecek
nesnelerin
konst
olması
ilkesel
olarak
doğru
bence.
Anlaşıldı mı
Emirhan?
Yani
sadece
closure
objektler
için
de
değil.
Hem
koda
bakan
hangi nesnelerin
mutable
immutable
olduğunu
bakar
bakmaz
görüyor.
Derleyici
de
gördüğü
için
derleyici
de
daha
iyi
optimizasyon
yapma
olanağına
kavuşuyor.
Evet
bu
bir
liste
dedik.
Mesela
Erkan
Efendim
Burgut
Fazıl
Thomas
Efendim
Biraz da
yalancı
arkadaşımız
olsun.
Richard
Richard'ın
aslında
Richard demiyorlar
ona başka bir şey
diyorlar ama
him
Efendim
Evet
Robert
Robert da
Bobby
Evet
Peki
bir tane de
females
nesnimiz olsun
Nuriye
Uriye
Fadime
Ayla
Canan
Nazlı
Eda
Ne olsun
Bilge
Evet
şimdi
her iki listeyi de
sıralayalım
buralara hızlı
geçiyorum
ve aynı
sıralama kriteriyle
males
sort
females
her ikisini de
yazdıralım
cprint
males
females
Şimdi
males
merge
Arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
sağ taraf değeri
ya da sol taraf değeri
diğer listeyi istiyor
Eğer
farklı bir
sıralama kriteriyle
sıralanmış iseler
o kriteri de
geçeceksiniz
ama şimdi ikisi de
left ile sıralandığı için
başka bir
argüman
geçmiyorum
şimdi
size'larını
yazdıralım
siyahat
erkekler
male size
kadınlar
female size
merge
işleminden sonra
ve
yine
erkekleri
yazdırıyorum
artık
tabi
ismi
uygun olmadı
çünkü
kadınları da
bünyesine
kaldı
evet
bakınız
erkekler
kadınlar
ikisi de
sıralı
ahmet
cengizhan
erkan
fazıl
emiran
virgül
unutulmuş
tipik
bak
ahmet
cengizhan
emiran
erkan
fazıl
murat
richard
robert
thomas
durgut
ayla bilge
canan
eda
fadime
huriye
nazlı
nuriye
ama
sıra bozulmadı
bakın
ahmet
ayla
bilge
canan
cengizhan
eda
emiran
erkan
fadime
giriyor
şimdi sıralama
kriterini
değiştirelim
ikisi de
büyükten
küçüğe
sıralansın
greater
ve
murci de
yine erkekler
kadınlar
sıfır
ama
guess
ikisi de
büyükten
küçüğe sıralı
arkadaşlar
tabi ki
merge
algoritması
ohen
karmaşıklığında
bir algoritma
şimdi merge
algoritmasını
ben hep
anlatırken
belki
C kursuna
katılmış
geçmişte
arkadaşlarım
varsa
hatırlayacaklar
hep şu
hikayeyi
anlatıyorum
eskiden
tabi
bu
C++
dersleri
yüz yüze
yapılıyordu
online
eğitime
geçmeden
önce
üniversite
öğrencisi
arkadaşlar
geliyordu
kursa
onlar da
böyle
okulda
sınavlarda
sorulan
soruları
falan
soruyorlardı
ve bütün
öğrencilerde
olmasa bile
çoğunluğunda
hocaların
öğrencilerin
hakkını
yediği
konusunda
genel bir
anlayış oluyor
dedi ki
bir öğrenci
işte dedi
Necati
ben sınava
girdim
aslında
soruyu
doğru yaptım
öğretmen
bana hiç
puan
vermedi
gidiş yoluma
da
öyle bir şey
varmıyor
dönemler
gidiş yolundan
puan
vermek
ona da
puan
vermedi
sana gösterebilir miyim
sen de bir görüşünü
söyle dedi
evet dedim
öğretmen
mörg sorusu
sormuş
işte sıralı
iki tane
dizi vermiş
bunu
üçüncü bir dizide
sıralı demiş
soru bu
ben de
nasıl yaptınız
diye sordum
arkadaşa
dedi ki
önce dedi
birinci
dizideki
öğeleri
ikisi de sıralı
bu arada
o üçüncü
diziye
kopyaladım
onun
bittiği yere
diğerlerini
kopyaladım
yani
diğer dizideki öğeleri
sonra bir
bubble sort
çektim
aynen kendi
ifadesiyle
önce sıralı
birleştirmiş
oldum
dedi
tabi
işin
şaka noktasını
anlıyorsunuz
değil mi
bu bubble sort
aşaması
bubble sort
on kare karmaşıklığında
bir algoritma
olduğu için
bu durumda
mörgü
on kare karmaşıklığında
gerçekleştirmiş
oluyor
olsa olması
gereken
karmaşıklık
on
evet
peki
mörgü de
gördük
şimdi sanırım
geriye
arkadaşlar
bir tek
splice
fonksiyonları
kaldı
şimdi
splice
bağlı listenin
deneyelim de
düğüm
içeren
implementasyonda
düğüm olan
veri yapılarının
avantajlarından
biri aslında
ne demek
splice
arkadaşlar
evet
bakınız
bağlı listede
düğümler var ya
mesela bunlar
düğüm
şimdi düğüm
içinde
data olan
iki tane
pointer olan
bir implementasyon
birimi
yani bu
kareler
birer düğümse
nod ise
bunların içinde
bir data var
iki tane de
pointer var
ama bakın
bu başka bir
liste
düğüm
hangi listenin
düğümü olduğunu
kendi bilir mi
cevap
hayır
dolayısıyla
bu iki
bağlı listede
aynı türden
öğeler tutuyorsa
örneğin
bu düğüm
bu listenin
düğümü iken
düğümü haline
gelebilir mi
cevap
evet
sadece
pointerların
değerini
değiştirmem
gerekir
değil mi
dolayısıyla
ilginç bir
şekilde
bağlı
listede
konumunu
birinci
bağlı listede
konumunu
bildiğim
noktadaki
bir öğeyi
oradan
silip
başka bir
bağlı
listede
yine bildiğim
bir konuma
onu eklemek
constant time'da
olacak
öyle değil mi
bakın
bunu silmek
constant time'da
değil mi
silmek derken
silseydim
constant time'da
yine aynı şekilde
ama bu sefer
silmeyeceğim de
bu düğümlerin
içindeki
pointer'lara
erişebildiğim için
sadece onu
tabiri caizse
pointer'larından
kopartacağım
yani
tespih
var ya
tespihteki
bir
baklayı
ya da
zincirdeki
bir baklayı
bir zincirden
çıkartıp
başka bir
zincire
takmak
gibi
bu
gerçekten
çok büyük
bir avantaj
böyle bir
avantaj
olmasaydı
buradan
silmek
için
bir kere
öğeyi
destroy
edecektik
ve
örneğin
vektörel
bir veri
yapısı
olsaydı
silme
maliyeti
arkadaşlar
linear
kompleksli
de olacaktı
buradan
sildiğim
öğey ya da
öğeyleri
diğer
konteynöre
eklemek için
orada tekrar
nesneleri
konstrakt
edecektim
ama
şimdi ne
olacak
splice
operasyonları
düğüm
içindeki
datayı
öldürmeyecek
sadece
düğümlerin
pointer'larıyla
ilgilenecek
yani
bunu
işte
şekilde
görüldüğü
gibi
buradan
söküp
arkadaşlar
başka bir yere
takacak
bu
operasyona
ya da
böyle
işlemlere
splice
deniyor
işte
listelerin
gerek
listing
forward
splice
isimli
fonksiyonları
var
hemen
splice
fonksiyonlarını
bir
görelim
hatta
şunlar
kalsın
alian diyor ki
splice
split
den mi
geliyor
hayır
yani
bence
hayır
şimdi yine de
sonuçta
etim
orucu uzmanı
değilim
ama
cevabım
hayır
yanılıyorsam da
özür dilerim
ayrı
fiiller
özür dilerim
evet
şimdi
arkadaşlar
şundan da birkaç tane
öğeyi silelim
şu
ecnevi
çıkartalım
bunlar kalsın
arkadaşlar
şimdi
birkaç tane
splice
over load
var ama
mantık
son derece
açık
şimdi
bir argüman
hangi listeye
splice
edilecekse
onu alacak
diğer argüman
mecbur
hangi
listeden
kopartılacaksa
referans
semantiyeli
onu almalı
sadece
iteratör
alarak
bunu yapamaz
ki
bir de
iteratör
konumu
ya da
konumlarını
alacak
burada
sıralı
olmakla
falan
ilgili
bir koşul
yok
tabii ki
mesela
males'in
arkadaşlar
splice'ı
birincisi
arkadaşlar
dikkat edin
bir
iteratör
istiyor
bir de
diğer listeyi
istiyor
mesela
males'in
bagini
females
ne yapacak
females'deki
üyeleri
males listesinin
başına
alacak
ama bu
bir kopyalama
değil
females'den
bunlar çıkmış
olacak
yani bu
operasyonun
sonunda
efendim
kadın sayısı
sıfır
olacak
ama
males size
diyelim bari
erkeksi
istemeyelim
o da
o kadar
artacak
diğerinin
size'ı
kadar
artacak
kadın listesini
yazdırsam
boş
ama erkek
listesini
yazdırdığımda
c
print
males
böylece
ne yaptı
ikinci listedeki
öğeleri
oradan
koparttı
ama onları
destroy etmedi
yani biz şimdi
string sınıfının
destroy
arttırının
içine
çağrıldığını
gösteren
bir yazı
yazsaydık
ki bunu
kendi
sınıf
nesneleriniz
için
yapabilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
destrakları
hiç çağrılmayacaktı
spice'ın
özelliği
bu
efendim
uzatmadan
çalıştıralım
kadın sayısı
male
size
ve gördüğünüz
gibi
benim verdiğim
konuma
splice edildi
arkadaşlar
eğer
konum
olarak
örneğin
ben
end konumunu
verseydim
sonuna
eklenmiş
olacaktı
diğer
overloadları
son derece
basit
yine
birinci
parametre
konum
a
arkadaşlar
eğer
diğer listeden
de tek
bir konum
verirseniz
örneğin
females
begin
tahmin ediyorsunuz
değil mi
erkek
listesine
kadın listesinden
kadın listesinin
begin
konumundaki
öğeyi alıyor
böylece
females'in
size biraz
alacak
nuriye
gidecek
ahmet'in
bulunduğu yere
nuriye
insert edilmiş
olacak
ya da
burada
örneğin
females
begin
yerine
next
females
begin
deseydim
buraya da
arkadaşlar
males
and
efendim
prev
virgül
iki
deseydim
arkadaşlar
bakın
bu durumda
da
evet
gördüğümüz
gibi
kim
eklendi
huriye
ama
bu konuma
eklendi
ve
son overload
o da son derece
basit
bir konum
değil
diğer listedeki
bir range
alacak
örneğin
males'in
splice'i
arkadaşlar
kolay olsun diye
males'in
end'i
females
ama
oradaki
bir range
örneğin
females
begin
next
yani
huriye'den
başlayacak
prev
females
end
böylece
arkadaşlar
huriye'den
edaya kadar
olanları
birinci
listenin
başına
sonuna
özür dilerim
ekleyecek
yani
cengizhan
huriye
fadime
ayla
canan
nazlı
eda olacak
females
listesinde
sadece
nuriye ile
bilge
kalacak
evet
kadın sayısı
erkek sayısı
gördüğümüz gibi
huriye
fadime
ayla
canan
nazlı
eda
eklendi
nuriye ve
bilge
listede
kaldı
şimdi
split'in
ne olduğunu
anladığınızı
umuyorum
split'in diyorum
splice'in
peki
arkadaşlar
listenin
fonksiyonları
da böyle
başta da
söylediğim gibi
sequence
container'lardaki
diğer fonksiyonlar
listede de
var
konumunu
bildiğimiz bir
yerden
ekleme ve silme
constant time'da
fakat
şimdi
tekli bağlı
liste
doğrusunu
söyleyip
isterseniz
stl'in
en kötü
konteynerı
kötü derken
kötü bir seçim
anlamında
söylemiyorum
ama
kullanım
miktarı
çok az
arkadaşlar
bir kere
modern
c++'la
eklendi
başta da
söylediğim gibi
ve
tekli
bağlı
liste
sınıfı
yalnız
neden
kötü
dediğime
gelince
standart
açık açık
bunu yazmış
sizde bakabilirsiniz
standarttan
ya da
cppreference.com'dan
ben de
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
forward list
yani
tekli bağlı
liste
sınıfı
c'de
yazılmış
implemente
edilmiş
tekli bağlı
liste
sınıfı
kodundan
bir
fazlalığı
ekstrası
olmayacak
efficiency
açısından
o yüzden
burada
arkadaşlar
size bile
tutulmuyor
yani
listedeki
ün sayısını
elde etmeniz
için
burada
size isimli
üye fonksiyon
yok
neden
çünkü
size'ın
olması
için
arkadaşlar
constant time
olması gerekiyor
STL
kurallarına
göre
oysa
tekli bağlı
listede
siz
ayrı bir
değişkende
size'ı
tutmazsanız
constant time'da
size'ı
elde etme
şansınız yok
dolayısıyla
anchor'dan
ilk düğüme
erişebilirsiniz
ilk düğümden
ikinci düğüme
erişebilirsiniz
tabi ki
notların içinde
tek bir
pointer var
böylece
anchor'dan
hareketle
bütün düğümlere
tek tek
erişebilirsiniz
yalnız
çifte bağlı
listeyle
double link liste
single link listin
önemli bir
farklılığını
herkesin hatırlaması
gerekiyor
bu farklılık ne
şimdi arkadaşlar
lütfen çok
dikkatli izlemeye
çalışın
eğer daha
önceden
konuyla
tanışmamışsanız
soru
çifte bağlı
listede
arkadaşlar
hatta
şöyle
bir dakika
bir de kalemle
işaretliyim
şunu silmek
istesem
ve benim
elimde
bunun
konumu
olsa
yani bunun
iteratör
konumu
olsa
bunu
listeden
silebilir
miyim
sadece bu
konum
elimde ise
cevap
tabi ki
internet
gençlik
terimiyle
tabi ki de
silerim
silmem için
hiçbir engel
yok
neden
resul
bravo
e çünkü
bunu
sildiğim zaman
benim
bunun
nextini
ve bunun da
previni
ne yapmam
gerekiyor
set etmem
çünkü bunun
nexti artık
bunu gösterecek
bu düğümün
içindeki
prevde
bunu gösterecek
dolayısıyla
sileceğim
düğümdeki
pointerlar
yardımıyla
sonrakine de
öncekine de
erişebilirim
ama
şimdi
aynı soruyu
tekli bağlı
liste için
sorsam
yani
desem ki
size
sevgili
arkadaşlar
şunu
silmek
istiyorum
ve yine
benim elimde
bunun
konumu
var
bunu
silemem
neden
arkadaşlar
çünkü
içinde
sadece
bunu
gösteren
bir
pointer var
ama
bunu
silmem
için
öncekinin
konumuna
ihtiyacım var
öyle değil mi
öncekinin
içindeki
nexti
set edip
o nexti
bunun
bu düğümün
adresi yapmam
gerekiyor
bravo
öncekine
binemediğimden
diyor
öncekine
erişemediğimden
bunların
birbirine
bağlanma
şansı yok
bu da şu
demek
şimdi soruyu
tekrar
soralım
bu sefer
farklı bir
şekilde
soralım
elimde
sevgili
arkadaşlar
elimde
benim
şu konum
varsa
kimi
silebilirim
soruyu
farklı
şekilde
sordum
elimde
bu konum
varsa
kimi
problemsiz
olarak
silebilirim
sonrakini
işte
bu nedenle
arkadaşlar
burada
erase
fonksiyonu
yerine
ismi
erase
after
denilen
bir fonksiyon
var
ismi
erase
after
olan
bir fonksiyon
var
o fonksiyona
bir iteratör
verdiğiniz zaman
o konumdan
sonraki
öğeyi
siliyor
yani
örneğin
şu
öğeyi
silmek için
erase
after
fonksiyonla
bunun
konumunu
geçeceksiniz
aynı durum
insert
işlemleri
için de
geçerli
mesela
arkadaşlar
buradaki
değer
olsa
buradaki
değer
olsa
nasıl
bir 5se
ve ben
7'nin
olduğu
konuma
6'ya
eklemek
istesem
yani
5 haline
getirmek
istesem
7'nin
konumu
elimdeyse
bunu yapamam
neden
çünkü
bu konuma
eklemek
için
yine
önceki
düğümün
içindeki
pointer'ı
set etmem
gerekiyor
eğer
benim elimde
değeri
7 olan
datayı
tutan
düğüm
varsa
o düğümün
adresi
varsa
ben ancak
6'yı
5'in
konumuna
ekleyebilirim
yani
yapabilirim
listedeki
düzeni
ama
yapamam
bu yüzden
yine
tahmin edin
arkadaşlar
burada
bir de
ne var
insert
fonksiyonu
yerine
arkadaşlar
insert
after
isimli
bir fonksiyon
var
insert
yerine
after
fonksiyonu
var
anlaşıldı
mı
yani
pekli
bağlı
listede
düğümlerin
içinde
tek bir
pointer
olması
a
forward
listin
iteratörünün
iteratör
kategorisine
liste
olduğundan
farklı olarak
bir daha
bi-directional
iteratör
olmak yerine
burada
forward
iteratör
iki
ekleme ve silme
işlemleri
STL'deki
genel konvensyon
gereği
verilen
konumlar
üstünden
yapılmasına
karşın
burada
o mümkün
olmadığı
için
ekleme ve
silme
fonksiyonlarının
isimleri
farklı
nedir
insert
after
ve
erase
after
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
bir problem
daha var
arkadaşlar
şimdi
iki tane
silme
fonksiyonu
var ya
biri
erase
verilen
konumdaki
öğeyi
siliyor
onun için
erase
after
dedik
bir de
range'i
siliyor
arkadaşlar
burada bir
problem de
şu
izleyin
bulalım
yine
şeklimiz
tam
bazı
fonksiyonlar
ne yapmayı
amaçlıyor
başa
ekleme
yapmayı
mesela
diyelim ki
konteynerımızdaki
öğeler
şöyle olsaydı
bu
üç
iki
bu
altı
ve ben
başa
dokuz
sekiz
biri
eklemek
istiyorum
normalde
insert
fonksiyonu
aldığı
konuma
birden
fazla
öğe
ekleyebilir
hatırladınız
değil mi
diğer
konteynerlarda
vardı
liste de
var
hatta
initializer list
parametreli
insert de var
ya da range
parametreli
insert var
ya da
en tane
şu değerden
öğeyi ekleyen
var
peki ya
ben
başa
eklemek
istiyorsam
ama burada
birincinin konumu
varsa
ben
buraya
ekleyebilirim
ama ben
birincinin
konumuna
ekleme
yapmam
gerekiyor
aslında
birincinin
konumuna
ekleme
yapabilmem
için
arkadaşlar
benim
ondan önceki
konuma ihtiyacım
var ama
ondan önce
bir konum
yok
bu ancak
konteynerın
içsel elemanlarına
erişerek
mümkün
o yüzden
buraya
şöyle
ilginç
bir fonksiyon
koymuşlar
normalde
konteynerların
begin
fonksiyonu
eqn'in
konumunu
veriyor ya
forward disk
konteynerında
bir de ismi
before begin
olan bir fonksiyon
var
before begin
fonksiyonu
aslında
sizin
d referans
etmeniz için
bir iteratör
vermiyor
before begin
fonksiyonunun
size verdiği
iteratör
konumunu
erase after'a
ya da
arkadaşlar
insert after'a
argüman olarak
geçip
ilk konumdan
başlayarak
öğeleri
silmek için
ya da
ilk konumun
ilk konuma
öğeleri
ekleyebilmek
için
çağırıyorsunuz
yani
burada
bir başka
önemli
fonksiyonda
before begin
fonksiyonu
anladık mı
adı üstünde
begin'den
önceki
konum
yani
aslında
bir soyutlama
neden size
öyle bir
konumu
veriyor
çünkü
ancak
onu
geçerseniz
insert after
ve
erase after
fonksiyonlarına
argüman olarak
o zaman
ilk öğenin
konumuna
ekleme yapabilirsiniz
ya da ilk öğeden
başlayarak
örneğin
birinci
silebilirsiniz
soyutlamayı ne anlamda
kullandınız
yani
implementasyon
karşılığı
değil
şu
before begin
aslında
ondan önce
bir nesne
yok
anladınız
değil mi
bu bir
abstraction
size diyor ki
ben sana
before begin
isimli bir fonksiyon
veriyorum
ilk öğeden
önceki konum
olmayan öğenin
konumunu veriyor
fiziksel olarak
aslında böyle bir şey
yok değil mi
o anlamda
kullandım
ama neden
bunu veriyor
size
bu
ilk öğenin
konumuna
after
içinde
geçen
nitelicisi
fonksiyonlara
argüman olarak
geçebilmeniz
için
bunun dışında
yine başta
söylediğim gibi
arkadaşlar
bir tane
anchor olduğu
için
ikinci bir
veri elemanında
size tutulmadığı
için
burada
size'ı elde
etmek
constant time'de
olmadığı
için
forward list'in
nesi yok
size üye
fonksiyonu yok
o zaman
kodlara geçmeden
şöyle bir
tekrar edecek
olursak
forward list
iteratörleri
forward iteratör
olan
notların
içinde
tek bir
pointer
olan
tek yönde
hareket
edebileceğiniz
fakat
C'deki
bir bağlı
listeye
eşdeğer olması
için
sadece
içinde
bir tane
anchor
tutan
ekleme ve
silme işlemlerinin
verilen
konuma değil
konumdan
sonrasına
yapılabildiği
arkadaşlar
bir
konteyner
burada
size üye
fonksiyonu
yok
peki
soru
tahmin etmeye
çalışın
ben
konteynerın
size'ını elde
etmek
istersem
ne yapacağım
yani
elimde bir tane
forward list var
forward listte
kaç tane
üye var
size yok
bu bir
soru
for döngüsü
cevabı
yanlış
yani yanlış
derken
for döngüsü
de tabii ki
olur da
daha kısa
bir cevap
var
cevap
for döngüsünü
içine alan
siz yazmayacaksınız
neydi
ilkemiz
türküm
doğruyum
çalışkanım
yasam
ve
ham döngüden
kaçınırım
i avoid
raw loops
o zaman
ham döngüden
kaçınıp
kimi çağıracağım
Muhammed Yusuf
hangi fonksiyonu
çağıracağım
cevap
range değil
iteratör fonksiyonları
hatırlayın
iki iteratör arasındaki
mesafeyi hesaplayan
distance
bravo
distance fonksiyonu
yani burada
size elde etmek için
distance fonksiyonunu
çağıracaksınız
o zaman
önce başlık dosyamızı
dahil edelim
burada başlık dosyamız
arkadaşlar
forward list
yani kendi
ayrı başlık
dosyası var
forward listin
string açılımı
s list
konstruktör grubu
aynı
yine copy
konstruktör
move
default
konstruktör
size
d
konstruktör
size
d
while
konstruktör
range
var
fonksiyonlara
bir bakmanızı
istiyorum
assign
yine atama
fonksiyonu
daha önce
görmüştük
assign
range
parametre
ama bildiğimiz
range değil
range
is kütübhanesindeki
parametre
az önce
söylediğim gibi
before begin
fonksiyonu
begin
bunların
konst literatör
döndüren
c
before begin
begin
c
and
arkadaşlar
clear
all
areas
insert
after
yerine
em
place
after
arkadaşlar
push
front yerine
em
place
front
empty
and
erase
after
front
get
allocator
insert
after
range
max
size
merge
operatör
atama
pop
front
prepend
range
bunlar hep
range kütübhanesinden
sonra gelenler
push
front
remove
if
resize
reverse
sort
splice yerine
splice
after
swap
unique
bir şey dikkatinizi
çekti mi
bakın burada
push front var
ama pushback
yok
neden pushback
çünkü pushback
constant
time'da
değil
pushback
constant
time'da
olması
için
son düğme
anchor
tutmanız
gerekiyor
ama son düğme
anchor
tutmuyor
dedim ya
minimal bir
tekli bağlı
liste diyor
str
anlaşıldı
anlaşıldı mı
arkadaşlar
bu arada
power liste
ilgili zaten
konuşmamız
gereken her şeyi
konuştuk
sadece
şu
insert
after
erase
bu fonksiyonları
bir görmenizi
istiyorum
şimdi
buraya
efendim
öğeleri
ekleyelim
ahmet
kerim
sadullah
nuri
hep erkek olmasın
ayşe
nihay
evet
oldu sanırım
tamam
bakalım
bizim
S listimizdeki
öğeler
bunlar
jprint
S list
onun için
var mı
fonksiyonumuz
bakalım
buraya
kadar
mesela
örneğe bakın
baştan
ekleme yapmak
için
S list
push
front
zeki
tekrar
yazıyor
ama
şimdi
izleyin
ya ben
başa
birden fazla
öğe eklemek
istiyorsam
S list
insert
after
bakın
insert
after
fonksiyonunun
initializer list
parametreli
örneğin
ya da range
parametreli
overloadları var
şimdi ben
şöyle yazarsam
S list
begin
initializer list
parametreli
parametreye
argüman
geçiyorum
büyük harfle
yazayım ki
onların
baştan
eklendiği
belli olsun
arkadaşlar
Ece
Nur
Gül
peki
bu arkadaşlarımı
nereye
insert etmiş
olduk
cevap
Ahmet'in
konumuna değil
bravo
Alian Bozkır
Ahmet ve
Kerim arasına
e peki
şimdi
nasıl olacak
da ben
az önce
Emirhan
sorduğunuz
sorunun cevabı
da burada
nasıl olacak
da ben
bir range
teki
öğeleri
ya da bir
efendim
örnekte
olduğu gibi
initializer list
teki
öğeleri
en başa
ekleyeyim
cevap
bundan bir
önceki konuma
ihtiyacım var
işte
soyutlama
derken
bunu kastettim
aslında ondan
bir önceki
konum
diye bir
yok
işte
before begin
fonksiyonunu
kullanacağımız
yer
burası
before begin
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
arkadaşlar
ya da
kullanacağım yerlerden
biri
burası
şimdi bakın
konum olarak
insert after'a
before begin'i
verdiğimde
bunu başardım
şimdi devam
edelim
yolumuza
ilk öğeyi
silmek için
s list
arkadaşlar
şu insert
after'ı
sileyim
ilk öğeyi
sadece
silmek
isteseydim
şöyle
yazacaktım
s list
pop front
ve
ilk öğeyi
yani
zeki'yi
silmiş oldum
ama
burada
erase after
fonksiyonunu
çağırsaydım
ve
erase after'ı
arkadaşlar
ben
bir konum
vereceğim
örneğin
ask list
begin
izleyin
e bu durumda
kimi silecek
ilk öğeyi değil
ikinci öğeyi silecek
ya da buraya
bir range
versem
o range'deki
öğeleri
değil
onun bir
sonrakinden
başlayarak
silecek
işte böyle durumlarda
da
konum olarak
silince köyelere
ilk öğeyi de
dahil etmek için
yine
erase after'ın
overloaduna
ne vermem gerekiyor
before begin
vermem gerekiyor
arkadaşlar bir de
burada
programcıların
neredeyse bu
FCL mülakatlarında
ya da
C++
mülakatlarında
çoğunlukla
sorulan
tek bir
forward list
sorusu var
bu da yine
üretimde
belki
karşımıza
çıkabilecek
bir senaryo
diyorlar ki
tekli
bağlı listeden
yani
S list
diyorum
forward list
size bir
değer veriyorlar
onu silmenizi
istiyorlar
hadi gelin
bunu
bir örneğini
yapalım
arkadaşlar
random
fill
sanırım
sanırım bunun için
ayrı bir
overload vardır
bakalım
yoksa
iptal edeceğim
S list
on
random
name
yokmuş
neyse
şöyle yapalım
bizde
arkadaşlar
evet
o
insert
fonksiyonunu
kullandığı için
şöyle yapalım
önemli değil
10 kez
önemli bir
döngüde
S list
push
front
fonksiyonuna
random
name'i
argüman
olarak
verelim
ve listemizi
yazdıralım
c
print
s list
şimdi bir
string değişken
oluyorum
string name
be out
kimi
silelim
c
name
buraya kadar
bir
derleyelim
mesela
kimi silelim
ben
tamer
dediğimde
silinecek
dolayısıyla
kunter
sabriye
petek
melek
belgin
abdi
olacak
ama
tabii ki
birden fazla
varsa
hepsini
silmek
istemiyorum
arkadaşlar
bu arada
bir not
hem list için
hem forward list için
buradaki
remove
fonksiyonu
ilk öğeyi
silmiyor
o öğelerin
tamamını
siliyor
onu söylemiştim
zaten
ama şimdi
o değere
sahip
ilk öğenin
silinmesi
gerekiyor
şimdi burada
problemin ne
olduğunu
tahmin ediyorsunuz
değil mi
benim
jülideyi
örneğin
silmem
için
jülidenin
konumuna
ihtiyacım
yok
jülidenin
konumunu
bulursam
yani örneğin
find fonksiyonuyla
find algoritmasıyla
jülideyi
bulursam
alihal
iş işten
geçmiş oluyor
çünkü
jülideyi
bulursam
olsa olsa
kimi silebilirim
rupeni
silebilirim
benim
jülideyi
silebilmem için
tayyarın
konumuna
ihtiyacım var
bravo
ancak
tayyarın
konumu
elimde olacak ki
arkadaşlar
ayyarın
konumu
elimdeyken
o iteratörü
kullanarak
erase after
argüman olarak
geçerek
silebilirim
şimdi bunun için
ne yapmamız
gerekiyor
bir düşünün
arkadaşlar
eğer kendiniz
bir algoritma
yazmazsanız
ki yazmakta
fayda var
onu da ben
genelde ödev
olarak veriyorum
listeyi
dolaşacaksınız
ve silincek öğeden
bir önceki öğenin
konumunu
bulacaksınız
başka bir yolu
doğrudan yok
o zaman
bunu
bir yapmaya
çalışalım
beraber
arkadaşlar
bunu yapmanın da
iki tane yolu
var
yine
bakın
iki site
olur
birincisi
listeyi
bir iteratörle
değil
iki iteratörle
dolaşmak
iteratörlerden
biri
ilk öğenin
konumunu
tutarak
başlarken
öbürü
before begin
değerinde olacak
dedim ya
before begin'in
kullanılacağı
bir başka
senaryo
daha var
yani şimdi
döngüye
başlarken
iteratörlerden
biri
ırmağın
konumunu
tutuyor
öbürü
before begin
ve ben
döngünler
durumda
iki iteratörde
biri
birer
arttırıyorum
yani
önde giden
iteratör
berivan
konumunu
tutarken
arkadan
gelen
iteratör
ırmak
konumunu
tutuyor
bu durumda
silince köyeyi
tutan
iteratör
jülidenin
konumunu
tutarken
diğeri
efecanın
konumunu
tutuyor ki
burada
döngüden
çıkacağız
ve döngüden
çıktığımızda
geriden gelen
iteratörü
erase after
fonksiyonuna
argüman olarak
vereceğiz
bunu yapmanın
bir başka
yolu
tahmin edin
tek bir
iteratör
kullanmak
ama
silinecek
değer mi
sorusunun
cevabını
almak için
iteratörü
dereferans
etmek yerine
next
vardı ya
next'in
döndürdüğü
iteratörü
dereferans
etmek
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani
iteratörümüz
örneğin
efecanın
konumundayken
next iter
etti
referans
ettiğimde
jüride
olduğunu
göreceğim
döngüden
çıkacağım
yine
o iteratör
konumundaki
öğeyi
sileceğim
herkes anladı mı
tamam
o zaman
ikisini de bir
kodlayalım
arkadaşlar
bu geriden gelen
iteratör olsun
o da iter
grev
eşittir
arkadaşlar
listemizin
ismi ne
s list'in
before begin'i
begin değil
şimdi
for döngüsü
auto
iter
eşittir
arkadaşlar
s list'in
begin'i
iter
eşit olmadığı
sürece
s list'in
end'i
artı artı
iter
grev
döngünler durumda
iki iteratörde
birer arttırıyorum
if
arkadaşlar
yıldız iter
eşit eşit
neyim ise
o zaman
döngüden çıktım
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
döngüden çıktığımda
arkadaşlar
ne diyeceğim
if
if yok artık
neydi
konteynerimiz
ismi
s list
erase
evet
s list
erase
iter
prep
erase
after
iter
prep
aynı şey
insert
için de
geçerli
mesela
burada
tabi son
konum olmadığında
kontrol etmemiz
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
mesela
julide'nin
nereye
ekleyelim
kimin
bulunduğu yere
ekleyelim
ikisini de
yazalım
kimin
bulunduğu
yere
ekleyelim
insert
after
iter
prep
mesela
muharremi
eklemek
isteyelim
ikisini de
yazmış
olalım
silmeyi de
ayrıca
yazarız
ve
c
print
eskis
silme
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
insert
after
yerine
erase
after
çağıracaktım
şunu
kapat
evet
kimin
bulunduğu yere
ekleyelim
yavuzun
bulunduğu yere
ekleyelim
eğer doğru
yapmışsak
ali
muharrem
yavuz
olacak
son
öğe içinde
sezenin
konumuna
ekleyelim
muharrem
sezen
olacak
sümeyye
konumuna
ekleyelim
arkadaşlar
muharrem
sümeyye
müslüm
olacak
aynı şey
silme
için de
geçerli
değil mi
ama
şimdi
bakınız
tabi ki
burada
bunu bir
predikate
bağlamak
isteseydik
burada
o koşulu
yazacaktık
ha
ama
şöyle de
yazabilirdik
değil mi
bu sefer
diğer
iteratörü
tamamen
kaldırıyorum
bakın
onun yerine
iter eşittir
arkadaşlar
eslistin
endi
değil
next
iter
prayer
eşit değil
eslistin
endi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
ve iter yok
artık
sadece
artı artı
iter
burada da
yine
next'i
kullanacağım
ve eklerken
yine
iter
previ
kullanacağım
kimin bulunduğu yere
ekleyelim
Leyla'nın
bulunduğu yere
ekleyelim
Muharrem
Leyla'nın
bulunduğu yere
eklendirin
tekli bağlı listemizde
böyle
şimdi sırada
İngilizce'de
associative
containers
diye geçen
grup var
arkadaşlar
ilk başta
söyleyeceklerimizi
en sonunda
en başta
söyleyelim
en sona
eklemek
istersek
Resul
zaten o örneği
yaptım bakın
en sona
ekleyeyim
bested
en sona
eklediğim zaman
zaten
insert after
fonksiyonla
son öğenin
konumunu
geçmiş oluyorum
anlaşıldı
son öğe mi
şunu mu
diyorsunuz
en sona
eklemek
istersem
en sona
eklemek
istersem
zaten
insert after
son öğenin
sonrasındaki
konumla
yani
end konumuyla
çağırmam
gerekiyor
anladınız
değil mi
ama zaten
en sona
eklemek
için
öyle bir
şeye
ihtiyacım
yok
zaten
end konumunu
insert after
verirsem
arkadaşlar
o sona
eklemiş
olurum
anlaşıldı mı
peki
aliyan tam
soruyu anlamadım
ama isterseniz
sonra bakalım
şimdi ben
asosiyeti
unutmayın
sonra bakacağım
arada
tam soruyu
anlamaya
çalışacağım
şimdi
vakit
kaybetmemek
için
ilgilenmiyorum
arkadaşlar
geldik
asosiyatif
konteynerlere
şimdi
asosiyatif
konteynerler
biraz zor
ama
dedi ki
en sonunda
söyleyeceğimizi
en başta
söyleyelim
arkadaşlar
aslında
buradaki
konteynerler
eğer
c++'dan
önce başka
programlama
dillerini
kullandıysanız
burada
onlarda
da
yine
tipik olarak
set
map
isimli
konteynerler
önce bu
konteynerlerin
ne olduğunu
anlamamız
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
bizdeki
isimleri
şöyle
set
ve
multi
set
map
ve
multi
map
bunların
oluşturduğu
gruba
asosiyatif
konteyner
deniyor
arkadaşlar
set şu
demek
içinde
değerler tutan
bir
collection
ve
bu değerler
bir sıralama
ilişkisiyle
tutuluyor
yani
bunların
konumu
ekleme ve
ekleme
işlemlerinde
şu konuma
ekle
diyemiyoruz
değerle
bir ekleme
işlemi
var
burada
işte o
değerle
ekleme
işlemi
için
uzun uzun
konuşacağız
ekivalans
dediğimiz
bir
kavram
var
dolayısıyla
asosiyatif
konteyner
terimi
aslında
burada
bunların
içsel
düzeninin
tipik olarak
arkadaşlar
binary
search
tree
veri yapısı
şeklinde
implemente
edilmesi
ve
değerle
ekleme
işleminin
yapılması
ikili arama
ağacı
veri yapısını
binary
search
tree
hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi
her nodun
içinde
yine
iki tane
düğüm var
düğümlerden
biri
kendinden
değerce
daha küçük
olan
öğeyi
tutan
düğümü
gösteriyor
diğeri
kendinden
daha büyük
olan
öğeyi
tutan
düğümü
gösteriyor
burada
bir
karşılaştırma
ilişkisi
var ve
buna
İngilizce'de
ekivalans
deniyor
ne demek
ekivalans
equality ile
birbirinden
farklı
kavramlar
arkadaşlar
equality
eşit eşit
operatörüyle
yaptığımız
karşılaştırma
demek
ekivalans
ise
karşılaştırmanın
eşitlik
karşılaştırmasının
aslında bir
relational
operatör
kullanılarak
örneğin
küçüktür
A
B
değil
A
B'den
küçük
değil
ama
aynı
zamanda
B'de
A'dan
küçük
değil
yani
öğelerin
haftaki
yerini
belirlemek
için
ya da
aradığım
öğenin
o değerde
olup olmadığını
sınamak için
her zaman
karşılaştırma
böyle yapılıyor
işte
bu da
zaten
bir template
parametresi
eğer burada
operasyon olarak
küçük türü
istiyorsanız
zaten
default
argüman olarak
stud
l'si alıyor
ama
siz burada
kullandığınız
karşılaştırma
operatörünün
küçüktür
değil
karşılaştırmanın
başka bir
operasyonla
yapılmasını
istiyorsanız
o zaman
onu
template
argümanı
olarak
vereceksiniz
mesela
less yerine
greater
verirse
içsel düzenek
büyüktür
operatörü
ile yapılan
karşılaştırma
ile yapılacak
yani
A büyüktür
B değil
B büyüktür
A değil
biçiminde
peki
bunların arasında
ne fark var
arkadaşlar
set veri
yapısı
buraya dikkat
set
collection'ı
container'ı
değerle
aramanın
eklemenin
değerle
silmenin
logaritmik
karmaşıklıkta
olduğu bir
veri yapısı
yani
örneğin
isimlerin
bir setini
oluşturursam
bu
set içinde
Emirhan
var mı
sorusunun
cevabını
almam için
işlem
karmaşıklığı
o
login
aynı
şekilde
silme
işlemi
içinde
setten
Alihan'ı
çıkartıyorum
o
login
sete
rasulü
ekliyorum
o
login
yani
değerle
ekleme de
silme de
arkadaşlar
değerle
erişme de
o
login
karmaşıklığında
sette
buraya
dikkat
sette
her
değerden
bir
tane
var
yani
örneğin
isimlerin
setini
oluştursam
oraya
Alihan'ı
koysam
ikinci kez
Alihan'ı
insert
etmek
istediğimde
insert
işlemi
yapılmayacak
anımsız davranış
ya da başarısızlık
yapılmayacak
ama
eklemeye çalışmakta
doğal bir işlem
yani ekleme işlemi
eklemenin yapılmaması ile
sonuçlanacak
arkadaşlar
veri yapısında
aranacak
değere
tipik olarak
key deniyor ya
set keylerden
oluşuyor
aramayı
key ile
yapıyorum
key'e karşılık
key'i buluyorum
bu da şu demek
o tipik
senaryoların
dışında
sette en çok
yaptığımız işlem
var mı
yok mu
sorgulaması
mesela ben
sınıftaki
bütün
arkadaşların
isimlerini
bir sete
koyarak
bu sınıfta
efendim
rasul var mı
necati var mı
ece var mı
bu sorgulamaları
o logan karmaşıklığında
yapabilirim
set ile
multi set
arasındaki
fark
setin
bir key'den
bir tane
tutabilmesi
ama
multi sette
bir key'de
birden fazla
bir key'den
bir anahtardan
birden fazla
olabilir
set ile
multi setin
farkı
bu
arkadaşlar
yani
sette
ikinci kez
sette olan
bir değeri
ekleme işlemi
yapılmazken
multi sette
yapılacak
dolayısıyla
eğer
aynı anahtardan
birden fazla
olması
sizin için
uygunsa
o zaman
arkadaşlar
multi set
kullanacaksınız
map ve
multi map
set ve multi setle
tamamen aynı
veri yapısı
aslında veri yapısı
olarak hiçbir fark
yok
bu arada
derleyicilerin
implementasyonu
tipik olarak
ben başka bir
implementasyon
görmedim
görenler varsa
söylesin
arkadaşlar
İngilizce'de
red black
binary
tree
binary search
kullanıyor
yani bu veri yapıları
ve algoritmalarda
bir terim
dengelenme
kat sayısı
yüksek
ikili
ara maaşları
set multi setle
map multi map
aynı veri yapısı
fakat
aradaki fark şu
set sadece
anahtar tutarken
yani sette tutulanlar
set ya da
multi sette tutulanlar
keylerken
map'te tutulanlar
key value pairleri
yani her
key'e karşılık
gelen bir value var
ben logaritmik
karbaşıklıkla
anahtarı arıyorum
buluyorum
ama
anahtarı bulduğum zaman
o anahtarın
kendisiyle
birlikte
o anahtara
karşılık gelen
değeri de
buluyorum
mesela
kişilerin
isimleri ve
telefon numaraları
anahtar
isim olsun
value
telefon numarası
olsun
ben isimle
logaritmik
karmaşıklıkla
arama yapıyorum
ama
isme karşı
örneğin
rasul ismiyle
arama yapacağım
ama rasulün
telefon numarasına
erişeceğim
burada amaç
anahtarla birlikte
o anahtara karşılık
gelen
arkadaşlar
value'ya
erişmek
yine map ile
multi map
arasındaki fark
map'te
bir öğeden
bir anahtardan
bir tane varken
multi map'te
birden fazla
olabilir
ama her ikisinde de
value'lar
tekrar edebilir
yani value'ların
arkadaşlar map'te
bir tane olması
gibi bir
zorunluluk yok
o zaman
dört tane
konteynerımız var
ama neredeyse
bunların
interfezleri
birebir
aynı
çok ufak
farklılıklar var
set
interfezleriyle
map
interfezindeki
farklılıklar
sette
tek bir
key tutulurken
map'te
gerçekten
key value
pair'in
tutulması
işte bakın
stud pair
veri yapısının da
türününde
standart kütüphanemizin
verdiği
iyi bilinmesini
gerektiren
senaryolardan biri de
map kullanımı
örneğin
map'i dolaşırken
iteratör konumundaki
öğelere eriştiğimde
öğeler birer
pair olacak
dolayısıyla
bir iteratör
konumundaki
pair'in
first'ü
key olacak
second'ı
value olacak
evet bir
ara verelim
saat
21.08
arkadaşlar
ya da
21.09
olmuş
21.30
da
devam ediyoruz
o zaman
hemen
setle
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
set
nasıl bir
template
biliyorsunuz
bütün
konteynerler
birer sınıf
çablonu
bu arada
setle
multi
setin
header
file'ı
başlık dosyası
set
yani
ayrı ayrı
header'ları yok
map'le
multi
map'in de
başlık dosyası
map
yani
seti ya da
multi
seti
kullanmak için
set başlık
dosyasını
map'i ya da
multi
map'i
kullanmak için
map
başlık dosyasını
include
edeceksiniz
set
konteynerı
şöyle bir
sınıf
şablonu
arkadaşlar
birinci
template
parametresi
sette
tutulacak
öğenin
türü
ikinci
template
parametresi
buna
popüler olarak
temperatör
deniyor
bu
ekleme
silme
işlemlerinde
eşitlik
karşılaştırması
ekivalans
karşılaştırmasında
kullanılacak
arkadaşlar
function
object'in
türki
default
argüman olarak
studless'i alıyor
studless'i alması
demek
karşılaştırma
işlemlerinin
küçüktür
operatörü
ile yapılması
demek
type name
key
on
eşittir
functional
başlık
dosyasındaki
less
function
object'inin
key
specialization
üçüncü
template
parametresi
yine
diğer
template'lerde
konteynerlarda
olduğu gibi
arkadaşlar
allocator
hep
allocator'ın
arkadaşlar
bellek yönetimini
gerçekleştiren
yani
bellek alanını
allocate eden
de allocate eden
o bellek alanında
öğenin
oluşturulmasını
sağlayan
sınıf
diyebiliriz
şimdilik
o zaman şöyle
diyeyim
type name
a
eşittir
stud
allocator'ın
yine
key
açılımı
evet
şurada bir
açısal parantez
eksik
plus
set
bu ne
demek
eğer
ikinci
template
parametresi
için
default
argüman
kullanırsanız
karşılaştırma
işlemleri
küçüktür
operatörü
ile yapılacak
eğer
ikinci
template
parametresi
için
örneğin
lessi
default
argümanı
kullanmak
yerine
setteki
iç
düzeneğin
büyükten
küçüğe
oluşmasını
istiyorsanız
yani
karşılaştırma
işlemlerinin
büyüktür
operatörü
ile yapılmasını
istiyorsanız
ikinci
template
parametresine
parametresi
olarak
greater'ın
key
açılımını
vereceksiniz
yani
şöyle yazdığım
zaman
set başlık
dosyasını
include
ediyorum
set'in
arkadaşlar
örneğin
int açılımı
demek
set'in
int virgül
less'in
int açılımı
demek
ama ben
less funglarını
kullanmak yerine
a
arkadaşlar
greater'ı
kullanabilirim
standart
function object
sınıfı
olarak
greater'ın
int açılımı
b
greater
kullanmak
yerine
kendim
bir
closure
type
oluşturabilirim
ya da
kendim
bir
function
object
type
oluşturabilirim
örneğin
class
comp
karşılaştırma
için
iki tane
V'yi
karşılaştıracak
bir
operatör
fonksiyonu
sağlarım
public
örneğin
operatör
arkadaşlar
fonksiyon
çağrı
int x
int y
geri dönüş
değeri
bul
const
doya
fonksiyon
örneğin
return
stud
abs
x
küçük
stud
abs
y
şimdi artık
kendi
function
object
type'ım
olduğu için
örneğin
set'in
int açılımı
yerine
set'in
int virgül
comp
açılımı
dersem
karşılaştırma
işlemleri
bu fonksiyona
yapılan
çağrıyla
gerçekleşecek
arkadaşlar
bu da ne
demek
eğer mutlak
değerleri
aynıysa
bunlar
aynı kabul
edilecek
örneğin
5'e
eklediğim zaman
eksi
5'e
ekleyemeyeceğim
eğer
set ise
tabi ki
karşılaştırma
kriteri
normal bir
fonksiyon
da olabilir
arkadaşlar
o zaman
fonksiyon
adresi
türünü
ikinci
template
argümanı
olarak
vermem
gerekiyor
ya da bu
bir
closure
object
olabilir
işte
burada
çok
önemli
lambda
ifadelerinde
bunu örnek
olarak
vermiştim
arkadaşlar
eğer
bir
lambda
ifadesini
bu amaçla
oluşturursanız
örneğin
auto
fcomp
eşittir
int x
int y
return
noktalı
örgül
ve şimdi
buraya dikkat
decltype
fcomp
arkadaşlar
hatırlıyor
musunuz
bilmiyorum
şimdi
bu
kod
ekleme
ve silme
işlemleri
yaptığımda
c++
öncesinde
syntax
hatası
oluşacak
çünkü
set
container'ı
bu
ikinci
template
parametrisi
türünden
bir nesneyi
default
construct
ediyor
fakat
c++
öncesinde
state
lambda
default
construct
değil
dolayısıyla
eğer c++
öncesinde
için
kod
yazıyorsanız
böyle bir durumda
setting
constructor'ına
bizim
komparatör
closure
object
nesnemizi
de
geçmemiz
gerekiyor
fakat
c++
itibariyle
artık
stateless
lambdalar
default
construct
olduğu
için
burada
doğrudan
default
construct
kullanabiliyorum
arkadaşlar
yalnız burada yapılan
çok çok tipik
ben programcıların
bu hatayı çok
yaptığını
görüyorum
bir hata var
şimdi
sizin
setinizde
ekleme
silme
arama işlemlerinde
karşılaştırma yapılıyor
değil mi
karşılaştırma nasıl yapılıyor
işte sizin verdiğiniz
komparatör
şöyle diyelim
buraya
küçüktür yerine
op yazayım
sizin fonksiyonunuz
iki kere
çağrılıyor
ve gerçekten
buradan
arkadaşlar
true değer elde edilirse
ikisi eşit kabul ediliyor
buna equivalence ilişkisi
deniyor
peki
mesela
ben şöyle bir fonksiyon
yazsam
arkadaşlar
burada küçüktür
yerine küçük eşit
desem
acaba buradaki
kont türünü
setin
karşılaştırma
kriteri olan
template argümanı
olarak kullanabilir miyim
cevap
hayır
çünkü
bakınız
programlamada
İngilizce'de şöyle
geçiyor
strict
weak
ordering
bu tür durumlarda
karşılaştırma için
kullanılacak
operasyonun
İngilizce'de
strict
weak
ordering
denilen
kurallar
setini
tamamen
karşılaması
gerekiyor
bu kurallar
şunlar
burayı
biraz daha
dikkatli izleyelim
çünkü
çok sık yapılan
bir hata
üretimde
yani burada
sağladığınız
operasyon
şimdi söyleyeceğim
dört tane
kriterden
birini bile
karşılamıyorsa
o sette
aynı durum
map
multi map
multi set için de
geçerli
komparatör türü
olarak
kullanılamaz
birinci koşul
sizin
arkadaşlar
operatörünüzün
ya da operasyonunuzun
antisimetrik
olması
olması şu
demek
eğer
x
operation
y
örneğin
küçüktür
kullanıyorsam
x küçüktür
y
arkadaşlar
trueysa
y
küçüktür
x
yani
sizin
operasyonunuzda
y
op
x
ne olmalı
bu
false olmalı
yani
a küçüktür
b ise
arkadaşlar
b küçüktür
a küçüktür
b trueysa
b küçüktür
a
false olmalı
buna
antisimetri
deniyor
iki
transitif
olmalı
sanıyorum
transitif
için
bizim
Türkçe'de
kullandığımız
terim
yanılıyorsam
düzelttim
matematikle
aram
çok uzun
süre
ilişkim
kesildi
çok uzun
süre
geçişken
mi
deniyordu
transitif
yerine
matematiği
kuvvetli bir arkadaşım
söylesin
Türkçe
terimlerde
arkadaşlar
transitif
olması
şu
demek
a b'den
küçükse
b'de
c'den
küçükse
a'da
c'den
küçük
olmak
zorunda
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
a'da
c'den
küçük
olmak
zorunda
mesela
diyelim ki
sizin
operasyonunuz
buna
true
verdi
buna
true
verdi
ama
buna
false
verdi
o zaman
sizin
operasyonunuz
böyle
davranıyorsa
komparator
olarak
kullanılamaz
burayı
herkes anladı
mı
arkadaşlar
bana
transitivity
deniyor
üçüncü
özellik
İngilizce
irreflexive
deniyor
arkadaşlar
irreflexive
olması
şu
demek
kendisiyle
karşılaştırma
yapıldığında
false
olmak
zorunda
kendisiyle
karşılaştırma
yapıldığında
false
mesela
bakın
az önceki örneğe
az önceki örnekte
dedim ki
örneğin küçük
eşit
olsaydı
bu
komparator
olarak
kullanılamazdı
hemen
zaten
küçük
eşitin
komparator
olarak
kullanılmayacağı
nereden
belli
çünkü
irrefleksif
olma
özelliği
bozuluyor
burada
küçük
yerine
x küçük
eşittir
x derseniz
arkadaşlar
true
olur mu
olur
oysa false
olmak zorunda
herkes anladı mı
evet
dördüncüsü de
arkadaşlar
buna da
ne deniyor
İngilizce'de
transitivity
of
equivalence
yani
equivalence'ın
geçişkenliği
o da şu demek
şimdi
a'nın
b'ye
eşit
olması
a
küçüktür
b'nin
yanlış
olması
ve aynı
zamanda
b
küçüktür
a'nın
yanlış
olması
değil mi
yani
eğer bu
doğruysa
a b'ye
ekibarant
kabul ediliyor
peki
aynı durum
b ve c
için varsa
b küçüktür
c
değilse
ve aynı
zamanda
c küçük
b değilse
o zaman
b de c'ye
ekibarant
bu durumda
a b'ye
ekibarant
açısından eşit
b de c'ye
bunun zorunlu
sonucu olarak
ne de
olmak zorunda
a da c'ye
ekibarant
olmak zorunda
yani
a küçüktür
c
değil
ve aynı
zamanda
c küçüktür
a
değil
bunun da
yine ne
olması gerekir
true olması
gerekir
anlaşıldı mı
tekrar söylüyorum
antisimetrik
özelliği
sağlamıyorsa
transitif
olma özelliğini
sağlamıyorsa
irrefleksif
olma özelliğini
sağlamıyorsa
transitivity
o equivalence
özelliğini
sağlamıyorsa
o zaman
arkadaşlar
komparatör olarak
kullanılması
hanımsız davranış
oluşturacak
buna dikkat
etmemiz gerekiyor
bu arada
templetler konusunda
gördüğümüz
alias template
kullanımına
çok tipik bir örnek
set
map
multi set
multi map
gibi konteynerlar
olabilir
neden
bakınız
diyelim ki
ben bir uygulamada
sık sık
set
konteynerını
kullanmak istiyorum
ama
set
konteynerında
komparatör olarak
standart
kütüphanenin
greater
function
object
türünü
kullanmak istiyorum
o zaman sürekli
şöyle yazmam
lazım
setin
örneğin
int virgül
greater'ın
int
açılımı
ama
bakka türler içinde
örneğin
setin
double virgül
greater'ın
double açılımı
setin
string virgül
arkadaşlar
greater'ın
string açılımı
böyle yazmak yerine
bir alias template
oluştursam
template type name'de
buraya dikkat
using
şu ismi kullanıyorum
gset
eşittir
stut setin
h virgül
tut
greater'ın
arkadaşlar
t açılımı
böylece
artık siz
bunları yazmak
yerine
örneğin
bunu yazmak
yerine
sadece
gsetin
int açılımı
demeniz
yeterli olacak
ya da
gsetin
double açılımı
ya da
gsetin
string açılımı
hele hele
bir de
özel bir
allocator
kullanıyorsanız
template type name'de
class
necati'nin
allocator'ı
böyle bir sınıf
olsa sözde
şimdi
allocator'da
işimiz daha da
zor
çünkü
üçüncü
template
parametresi
yani ben
şöyle yazmak
zorundayım
setin
int virgül
l'si
kullanmak
istesem bile
l'si artık
yazacağım ki
çünkü
daha sağdaki
template
argümanını
yazmak
zorundayım
şimdi de
işte
diyeceğim ki
necalloc'un
int açılımı
ama
şimdi
burada da
mesela
using
isme
bakmayın
my set
pipe
t
şöyle yazabilirim
setin t virgül
stut
l'sin
t virgül
arkadaşlar
stut
greater'ın
değil de
stut
pardon
necalloc'un
t açılımı
bu durumda
ben
setin
arkadaşlar
my
set
t'nin
int
açılımı
dediğimde
istediğim türü
kastetmiş olacağım
yani
demek istediğim bu tür durumlarda
alias template kullanmak
kodun yazılmasına
okunmasını
kolaylaştırıyor
şimdi
setin arka plandaki
implementasyonu
aslında
binary search tree
dengelenmiş
tipik olarak
red black tree
bu da şu demek
siz
iteratör
semantiğiyle
ya da
ona açılan
range based
for loopla
bir seti
dolaştığınız zaman
karşılaştırma
kriteri olarak
ne kullanıyorsanız
o karşılaştırma
kriterine göre
küçükten büyüğe
doğru dolaşacaksınız
hadi bunu bir gösterelim
mesela
bakınız
setin
int
açılımı
my set
ve ben
100 kez
dönen bir döngüyle
my setin
birazdan detaylı
inceleyeceğimiz
insert fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaparak
diyelim ki
sıfırla
arkadaşlar
1000 arasında
rastgele
bir sayı
eklemiş olayım
şimdi buradan çıkan
birkaç tane
sonuca
bakınız
bir
bu işlemden
sonra
setin
sayısının
olma garantisi
var mı
cevap
tabii ki
hayır
çünkü
aynı rastgele
sayı
üretilmişse
ikinci kez
insert etme
gerçekleşmeyecek
dolayısıyla
my setin
size'ını
yazdıralım
my setin
size'ı
1000 de olabilir
daha küçük bir sayı da
olabilir
ama 1000 olma ihtimali
bu örnekte
çok çok
zayıf
değil mi
evet
bakın
sadece ve
sadece
eğer bu
setin
int açılımı
değil de
multi setin
int açılımı
olsaydı
size'ın
1000 olma
garantisi
var mıydı
Resul
Alihan
cevap
kesinlikle
çünkü
aynı değer
olsa da
insert işlemi
gerçekleşecek
gördüğünüz gibi
devam
peki şimdi
ben
a
iteratör
semantiğiyle
b
range
base
for loop
ise aynı şey
aslında
range
base
for loop
'a da
bir saat
zaman ayıracağım
önümüzdeki
haftalarda
ister şöyle
yazın
port
auto
iter
eşittir
my setin
c
bag'ini
iter
eşit olmadığı
sürece
my setin
c
endi
artı
iter
ve yine
iter'i
direferans edin
küçükten büyüğe
olarak
elemanlara
erişeceksiniz
görüyorsunuz
eğer
arkadaşlar
böyle yazmakla
ki önermiyorum
böyle yazmayı
ne kullanmak
aynı
range
base
for loop
for
örneğin
const
auto
i
burada referans
semantiği olmasının
bir sağlayacağı
fayda yok
my set
see
out
i
arka planda
derleyicinin oluşturduğu
kod yine bir
iteratör döngüsü
ama bu setin
int açılımı
değil de
setin
int virgül
greater
açılımı
olsaydı
greater'ın
int açılımı
şimdi
dolaşırken
bu sefer de
karşılaştırma
büyüktür
operatörüyle
yapıldığı için
büyükten küçüğe
dolaşmış
olacaktım
arkadaşlar
ya da
şuna bakın
rand
ya da şöyle
olsun
i rand
eksi
efendim
bin
artı
ama
komparatör
olarak
az önceki
mutlak değer
komparatörünü
kullanayım
const
auto
f
eşittir
lambda
int x
int y
return
abs x
küçük
abs y
setin
int virgül
decal type
f
açılımı
bakın
şimdi
dolaşıyorum
artık
karşılaştırma
kriteri bu
olduğu için
görüyorsunuz
eksi
gördük
değil mi
sonuçta siz
dolaşırken
sözde
sıralı
olarak
dolaşıyorsunuz
ama tabi ki
arka plandaki
dolaşma
aslında
recursive
olarak
ikili arama
ağacındaki
dolaşım
onda nasıl olduğunu
veri yapıları
ve algoritmalar
konusundan
bildiğinizi
varsayıyorum
bilmeseniz de
şu anda çok da
önemli değil
arkadaşlar
o zaman
komparatör
parametresinin
ne anlama
geldiğini
gördük
creator
kullanılabileceğini
ya da
kendi
komparatörümüzü
kendimizin
oluşturabileceğimizi
söyledik
şimdi
gelelim
setin
interfeysine
associative
containerların
interfeysi
sequence
containerlarından
biraz
farklı
yani
ortak
operasyonları
var
ama
ortak
olmayan
operasyonları
da var
ve burada
bazı
operasyonlarla
muhtemelen
bazı arkadaşlarım
ilk defa
tanışmış
olacak
hadi bakalım
nelerimiz
var
önce
yine şöyle
hepsini bir
sıradan
isimlerini
görelim
setin
int açılımı
myset
arkadaşlar
constructor grubunda
artık burada
doğal olarak
size t
parametreli
constructor yok
default
constructor var
initializer list
tabi ki
copy
constructor
ve move
constructor var
ama
initializer
ne yok
demin söyledim
fill
constructor yok
zaten anlamlı
da olmazdı
ya da size t
parametreli
constructor yok
yine burada
sequence
containerlarda
olan
örneğin
resize
fonksiyonu
yok
hemen
fonksiyonlarımızı
bir görelim
arkadaşlar
bakın
artık
çok daha
hızlı
ilerleyeceğiz
iteratör fonksiyonlarında
hiç sadece
ismini
söyleyerek
geçiyorum
begin
c begin
c end
clear
erase
o anlamında
bütün
containerlarda
var
array hariç
contains
arkadaşlar
c plus plus
20 standardı
ile eklendi
arama fonksiyonu
yani aranan
değer var mı
yok mu
count
aranan
değerden
kaç tane
var
cr
begin
end
and place
insert
ın karşılığı
and place
hint
insert
bir overload
kodunun karşılığı
empty
diğer
konteynerlarda
da olan
is empty
anlamında
empty
iteratör
veren
fonksiyon
equal
range
ayrıca
konuşmamız
gerekiyor
erase
yine
iteratör
konumu
ve iteratör
payliyle
yani
iki iteratör
range'ini
iki iteratörle
belirlenen
range'deki
öğeleri
siliyor
diğer
konteynerlarda
da aynı
extract
yine
c++
arkadaşlar
20 standartıyla
eklenen
önemli fonksiyon
anlatacağım
find fonksiyonu
get
al
find
arama fonksiyonu
burada tabi
arama
logaritmik
karmaşıklıkta
olduğu için
stut find
algoritması
yerine
sınıfın
find isimli
üye fonksiyonunu
kullanıyoruz
get
allocator
allocator'ı
get ediyor
insert
fonksiyonu
yani sete
yeni bir eleman
eklemek için
insert range
yine
arkadaşlar
c++
key
comp
anahtarı
karşılaştıran
function
object'i
get ediyor
lower
bound'u
uzun uzun
konuşmamız
gerekiyor
max
size
bütün
konteynerlarda
var
merge
işte
yine
iki tane
seti
birleştiriyor
bir set
başka bir
seti
bünyesine
katıyor
operatör atama
rbegin
rand
size
swap
ve
upper bound
value comp
yine key comp ile
aynı
şimdi burada
öncelikle
Emran Çelik
declet type ile
verilmesinin
sebebi
arkadaşlar
declet type ile
verilmesinin
sebebi
Emran şu
çok kısa bir cevap
vereyim
önce arkadaşıma
şimdi
ben
hamlet
argümanı
olarak
türü
vermek
zorundayım
fakat
tür
elimde
doğrudan
yok
çünkü
lambda
ifadesinden
derleyicinin
oluşturduğu
türe
closure
type
deniyor
fakat
o türün
doğrudan
bir ismi
yok
derleyici
biliyor
dolayısıyla
f nesnesi
hangi türdense
ben
onun
türünü
veriyorum
şimdi burada
türünü
dinamik olarak
belirleme
terimi
doğru
olmaz
Emran
çünkü
dinamik
dediğimiz zaman
siz o anlamda
kullanmamış
olabilirsiniz
dinamik
dediğimiz zaman
run time'a
yönelik
anlamında
oysa
burada
tam tersi
dinamik değil
statik
compile time'da
yani
derleyici
bu türün
ne olduğunu
run time'da
mı anlıyor
yoksa
compile time'da
mı anlıyor
cevap
compile time'da
anlıyor
değil mi
run time'da
anlaşılmıyor
değil mi
derleyici
koda bakarak
burada
türü anlıyor
dolayısıyla
buraya bir tür
yazmam lazım
bakın
aynı durum
buraya dikkat
bir fonksiyon
kullanmam
durumunda da
geçerli
Emran
sorunuza
cevap olarak
bir tamamlayıcı
bilgi daha vereyim
mesela burada
gerçekten şöyle
bir fonksiyon
olabilirdi
ismi
comp olan
bir fonksiyon
geri dönüş
değeri
bul
parametreleri
int x
int y
diyelim ki
fonksiyonun
kodu
yine aynı şekilde
yani bu kod
bir tane arkadaşlarım
izlesinler
şimdi soru
ben bu
fonksiyonun
türünü
sette
template argümanı
yapabilir miyim
cevap
evet
peki bu durumda
nasıl yapacağım
son derece
basit
diyeceğim ki
setin int virgül
comp'un
adresi olan
tür
comp'un
adresi olan
türü
ya şöyle
yazacağım
decletype
adres
comp
emran takip
edebiliyor muyuz
ya da
bu durumda
tabi fonksiyonun
adresini de fonksiyona
göndermem
gerekecek
yani
constructora
ya da
aslında ben
bu türün
ne olduğunu
biliyorum
siz de
biliyorsunuz
böyle bir
fonksiyonun
adresi olan
tür nedir
emran çelik
bu türdür
değil mi
bul
aç parantez
yıldız
arkadaşlar
int
bakın bu
bir function
pointer type
değil mi
ister böyle
yazayım
ister buraya
decletype
adres
comp
diyeyim
bu tür
elde edilecek
decletype
ne olduğunu
biliyorsunuz
şimdi
biraz daha
ilerleyebilmek
için
setin
interfeisinde
değil
genel olarak
algoritmalarda
da önemli
olduğu için
önce
lower bound
upper bound
equal range
ne demek
hem onları
anlatayım
hem de
bu sayede
STL'deki
lower bound
upper bound
ve
equal range
fonksiyonlarını
görelim
bakınız
lower bound
upper bound
ve equal range
STL'de
global algoritmalar
yani fonksiyon
şablonları
onları algoritma
diyoruz ya
ama
set map
gibi
konteynerların
onların da
üye fonksiyonları
var
az önce gördünüz
lower bound
upper bound
equal range
o yüzden
muhtemelen
dersi dinleyen
arkadaşlarımın
bir kısmı
bu terimlerle
ilk kez
tanışacağı için
lower bound'un
upper bound'un
ve
equal range'in
ne olduğunu
önce konuşalım
elimizde
belirli bir
sıralama kriterine
göre sıralanmış
bir range var
mesela
bound sayıların
oluşturduğu
bir range
sıralama kriteri
küçükten büyüye
böyle gidiyor
şimdi
soru
soruya dikkat
elimde bir değer var
diyelim ki
bunu
bu veri yapısına
insert edeceğim
yani
3 tane
25 varken
4 tane
25 olacak
şu sorunun
cevabını
verebilir misiniz
bunu
insert edebileceğim
ilk konum
hangi konum
eğer soruyu
anladıysanız
sorunun cevabının
şu olduğunu
söylemelisiniz
nece bu konum
öyle değil mi
çünkü bu konuma
insert ettiğimde
arkadaşlar
benim 25'im
bu 25'in
yerine gelecek
herkesi
akip edebiliyor
mu
arkadaşlar
işte
bir değerin
sıralı
bir ayınca
insert edilebileceği
ilk konuma
o değerin
lower bound
deniyor
o zaman
25 değeri için
lower bound
hangi konum
hadi buraya
lower bound
anlamında
l koyalım
bu konum
soru
soruya dikkat
25'i
insert edebileceğim
son konum
hangisi
sırayı bozmadan
tabi
arkadaşlar
o konumda
hahan can
bravo
bu konum
değil mi
kesinlikle
işte bu konuma da
arkadaşlar
upper bound
deniyor
yani
lower bound
anahtarı
ekleyebileceğimiz
sırayı bozmadan
ilk konum
lower bound
upper bound
da son konum
aslında
bunu şöyle de
tanımlayabilirdim
aynı şey
bakınız
lower bound
öyle bir
konum ki
o konum
anahtardan
büyük ya da
eşit olan
ilk öyenin
konumu
şimdi
anahtarın
25 olduğunu
düşünürseniz
bu tanımda
doğru değil mi
25'ten
büyük eşit olan
ilk öyenin
konumu
burası
değil mi
upper bound
da
anahtardan
büyük olan
ilk öyenin
konumu
o zaman
upper bound
da
25'ten
daha büyük olan
ilk öyenin
konumu
burası
değil mi
şimdi
doğru band
ve upper bound
anladık mı
şimdi birkaç tane
soru sorayım
soru
lower bound
ile upper bound
bir range
olarak kullanırsam
o range
de
hangi öyler
vardır
mesela
25'in
lower bound
ile upper bound
bir range
olarak kullanırsam
o range
de
25'ler vardır
bravo
olsam
kan
öyle değil mi
işte bakın
buna
equal range
deniyor
yani
equal range
normal
bizim
C++'daki
range
hani
birinci öye
dahil
ikinci öye
ikinci konum
hariç
lower bound
ile
upper bound
o konumu
peki şimdi
soru
ilk soruya
doğru cevap
verdiniz
25 için
equal range
de
yani
lower bound
upper bound
range'inde
sadece
25'ler var
distance'ı
hatırlayın
lower bound
upper bound
distance'ındaki
distance'ın
değeri ne
cevap
o anahtardan
kaç tane
olduğu
öyle değil mi
ayağın
3 demek
3 tane
25 var
demek
şimdi
soruyu
başka bir
değer için
soralım
arkadaşlar
16 için
lower bound
neresi
cevap
16'dan
büyük
ya da
eşit olan
yani
16'yı
insert
edebileceğimiz
ilk konu
peki
16 için
upper bound
neresi
16'dan
büyük olan
ilk öyenin
konumu
yani
16'yı
insert
edebileceğim
son konum
o da burası
o zaman
sıralı veri
yapısında
anahtar yoksa
şunu diyebilir miyiz
lower bound
upper bound
birbirine
eşittir
lower bound
upper bound
birbirine
eşit olması
ne demek
equal range
boştur
yani
equal range'in
distansı
sıfırdır
equal range'in
distansı
demek
o anahtardan
kaç tane var
hali hazırda
demek
burada
kafanıza takılan
bir şey var mı
arkadaşlar
peki
sıralama
ilişkisiyle
ben
sette olmayan
ama
setteki bütün
öğelerden
multi map'te
özellikle
mevcut
bu özellikler
çünkü zaten
bakın bu set
olamaz ki
sette de
mevcut
multi sette de
anlaşıldı mı
arkadaşlar
ama şimdi
bunların
set ya da
multi set
olması
gerekmiyor
sette neden
kullanılmasın
bakın
yani
sette bu
kavramlar
yok değil ki
siz kullanmayabilirsiniz
ama o kullanılmayacağı
anlamına
geliyor ki
mesela
söyleyin
13'ün
lower bound'u
neresi
burası
13'ün
upper bound'u
neresi
13'ün
upper bound'u
da burası
ama
sette
equal
eğer sette
anahtardan
bir tane
varsa zaten
en fazla
bir tane
olabilir
arkadaşlar
equal range'in
distansı
her zaman
birdir
olsan
bir tane
olması
evet
garantı altında
ama bu
hiç işe
yaramayacak
anlamına
gelmiyor ki
şimdi
onun tipik
bir örneğini
yapacağız
zaten
şimdi
STL'e
gelelim
arkadaşlar
STL'de
gerçekten
3 tane
algoritma
var
lower bound
upper bound
ve equal range
çünkü
sıralı veri yapısı
set olmak
zorunda
değil ki
yani
set için
kendi
üye fonksiyonlarını
kullanacaksınız
ama örneğin
vektör için
deck için
array için
string için
yani sıralı
diğer
konteynerler için
lower bound
upper bound
equal range
algoritmalarını
kullanacaksınız
hemen onları
görelim
bakınız
bir
lower bound
arkadaşlar
dikkat ederseniz
lower bound
forward
iteratör
range
alıyor
bir tane de
değer alıyor
ve size
iteratör
döndürüyor
ama
tabii ki
iki tane
overloadu var
neden iki tane
bu soruyu o kadar
çok sorduk ki
daha önce
cevap
default
overloadu
sıralamanın
less ne
yapıldığını
kabul ediyor
ama
diğer overloadu
sıralama kriteri
olan binary
prediketi
alıyor
anlaşıldı
mı
upper bound
aynı şekilde
lower bound
upper bound
iteratör
döndürüyor
arkadaşlar
equal range
ise
lower bound
upper bound
iteratörlerinin
ikisini
birden
döndürüyor
o da
nasıl mümkün
cevap
söyleyin
iteratör
bravo olsam
pair'i döndürüyor
o zaman
lower bound
iteratör
upper bound
ama
equal range
iteratör
pair'i döndürüyor
yani
first to
lower bound
arkadaşlar
second to
upper bound
hemen bunu bir örnek
üstünde görelim
vektörün
vektörü
ekleyelim
başlık dosyamızı
vektörün
int açılımı
efendim
vek
random fill
arkadaşlar
20 tane
ama değerlere bakın
sıfırla
9 arasında
değer
bu da 30 tane olsun
ve bunu
küçükten büyüğe sıralıyorum
sort
vek begin
vek end
ve yazdırıyorum
j print
vek
şimdi
zaman kaybetmemek için
lower bound
upper bound
equal range
için
kullanacağım
anahtar
sabit olsun
örneğin
7 olsun
lower bound
çağırıyorum
auto
iter
arkadaşlar
lower
eşittir
stut
lower bound
vek begin
vek end
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
hatta şöyle yapalım
ya
sizin daha iyi görmeyiz
0 5
diyelim
buna da
şimdi bakın
see out
distance
weight begin
ya da
vektör olduğu için
kısa keselim
arkadaşlar
iter
lower
index
for
lower bound
eşittir
ister
distance'ı
kullanın
ister
iter
lower
eksi
vek
begin
şimdi buraya kadar bir koşturalım
bakalım
arkadaşlar bakın
index
for lower bound
yani
aslında
şu konum
öyle değil mi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
eğer upper bound'u yazdırsaydım bu örnekler ne olacaktı
şu 4'ün indeksi olan 23 olacaktı onu da yazdıralım
auto
iter
upper
upper bound
vekbegin vekent 3
index
for
upper bound
iter
upper
eksi vekbegin
hatta
biraz kolay olsun diye
2'ye
bakalım
evet bakın
index
for lower bound
arkadaşlar
şurası
index
for upper bound
burası
takip edebiliyor muyuz
tabi ki
see out
distance
önce equal range'i dolaşayım
see out
equal range
bakınız
e benim zaten range print eden bir fonksiyonum var
c print
bunun ismini de r print olarak değiştireyim
arkadaşlar
lower bound
virgül
upper bound
iter lower
özür dilerim
isimleri
iter lower
iter
upper
o zaman
bu range'i yazdıran bir fonksiyon ise
c print
sadece
ikileri yazması gerekir
değil mi?
kaç tane iki varsa
onları yazdıracak
görüyor musunuz?
ve son olarak
distance'ı yazdırsam
c out
distance
for
equal range
arkadaşlar
o da
is in
slow distance
lower bound
virgül
upper bound
ay yine lower bound
upper bound yazdım
ne yazacaktım?
iter lower
iter
upper
örnek
gayet açık
şimdi
biraz sabırlı
olmanızı isteyeceğim
distance
for equal range
arkadaşlar
eğer amacım
gerçekten
equal range'i elde etmek
olsaydı
bu örnek
tamamen size
göstermek için
o zaman
zaten şöyle
yazabilirdim
bu sefer
burayı çok
dikkatli izleyelim
lower bound
upper bound
yerine
equal range
fonksiyonunu
çağıracağım
equal
range
yalnız
equal range
bana
arkadaşlar
bir
iteratör
heyeri verecek
dolayısıyla
eğer
şimdi ben
şöyle yazarsam
auto
it
pp
iteratör
heyresinizde
arkadaşlar
benim
lower bound
upper bound
kullanmam için
bunun
first'ünü ve
second'ını
kullanmam
gerekir
mesela
cprint
sadece
bir örnek
itp'nin
first'ü
lower bound
iteratörü
itp'nin
second'ı
upper bound
iteratörü
o zaman
bu rençteki
öğeleri
yazacak
ya da
arkadaşlar
distance
fonksiyonunu
itp'nin
first'ü ve
second'ını
argüman
olarak gönderirsem
bu durumda
yine
bu
distance
değerini
elde edeceğim
öyle değil mi
tabi
bu tür durumlarda
çoğu zaman
en iyi seçenek
arkadaşlar ne
structured binding
şimdi structured binding'i
kullanırsam
auto
ki onu bir derse
anlatacağımı
söylemiştim
bakın yine
iter lower
iter
upper
böylece
p'yi
paylaştırmış
olacağım
artık kodun
geri kalan
kısmı
önceki kod
gibi
olabilir
yani
şurayı
aynı isimleri
seçtim ya
gördük mü
arkadaşlar
arkadaşlar şimdi az önce
arkadaşım demişti ki
sette bunun
ne özelliği
olabilir
ben sette değil de
vektörde göstereyim
mesela çok klasik
bir mülakat
sorusu
mülakat sorusu
var
diyorlar ki
elinizde bir
vektör
olacak
vektörün
string açılımı
svek
bu vektöre
sürekli eleman
eklenecek
ama sıra
bozulmayacak
hep küçükten
büyüğe sıralamasını
koruyacaksınız
hemen sorunun cevabını
tahmin edebiliyorsunuz
değil mi
insert işlemini
sürekli
lower bound
ya da upper bound
aldığınız
konuma yaparsanız
vektör her zaman
sıralı olarak
kalır
değil mi
hadi bir örnek
yapalım
mesela
vektöre
sonuçta
arkadaşlar
on
vektörün
sayısı
on birden
küçük olduğu
sürece
while
svek'in
sayı
ya da
doğrudan
before dönemüsü
yapalım
daha da
kolaylaştıralım
bakın
şimdi
string
s
eşittir
random
name
siyat
s
eklenecek
svek'in
insert'ü
insert fonksiyonu
benden
konum istiyor
değil mi
lower bound
daha açık olsun
diye
normalde
doğrudan da
yazabilirdim
o da itereşittir
lower bound
svek begin
svek end
arkadaşlar
s
ve şimdi
svek'in
insert'ü
biter
s
c print
void
get card
ve bakın
gayet güzel
sırının
bozulmadan
döngünler durumda
eklemenin
yapıldığını
göreceksiniz
cansu
eklenecek
yanlış
yazmışım
c
print
eski
c
print
svek
evet
cansu
eklenecek
şimdi
başka isim
gelecek
erdem
eklenecek
tamer
bakın
erdem
tamer
sıra bozulmadan
eklemesi gereken
yere eklendi
ziya
eklenecek
erdem
tamer
ziya
sidre
eklenecek
erdem
sidre
tamer
ziya
çünkü
hep lower
bound'unu
buluyorum
ama yine
burada
bir tane
var
kim
sormuştu
o soruyu
bir tane
olduğunda
ne önemi var
demişti ya
bir arkadaşım
evet
hilme
eklenecek
erdem
hilmi
sidre
tamer
ziya
cahit
eklenecek
erdem
hilmi
sidre
tamer
ziya
asım
en başa
geldi
sinem
sidre
ile
tamerin
arasına
geldi
azmi
arkadaşlar
asımdan
sonraya
geldi
efendim
nurullah
hilmi
ile sidre
arasına
geldi
gördünüz
değil mi
bu vektörle
ya da sıralı
rençlerle
ilgili sorulan
tipik sorulardan
bir tanesi
şimdi ben
hem size
lower bound
upper bound
equal range
algoritmalarını
göstermiş oldum
arkadaşlar
bu pekala
liste de
olabilirdi
bakınız
listin
string açılımı
kontrol
a
svec
slist
replace all
bakın
power literatör
olduğu için
hiçbir şey
değişmeyecek
şu anda da
vektörde değil
aynı işi
listede yapıyorum
süleyman
cehan süleyman
cehan muzaffer
süleyman
gördünüz
değil mi
getkarı da
kaldırayım
evet
günay
ata günay
ata derya
günay
tabi ki
burada
diğer
overloadu da
bilmenizde
hatırlamanızda
fayda var
mesela şöyle
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
izleyin
lower bounda
bu kez
sıralama kriterinde
girmem
gerekecekti
s
arkadaşlar
bakın
şimdi bu
lisi kullanıyor
ama
diğer overload
son parametre
görüyorsunuz
binary
predikat
o zaman şöyle
olacak değil mi
s
örneğin
greater
evet
şimdi artık
büyükten küçüğe
bir de böyle
bakalım
arkadaşlar
evet
cihan
saniye cihan
daha büyük
yaşta değil
sanıyorum kısa
teoman
saniye cihan
caner
teoman
saniye
ediz
cihan
caner
arkadaşlar
kim geldi
cahit geldi
sonra
sidre geldi
keoman
dan
sonra
melek
geldi
saniye
ile ediz
arasına
öyle
anlaşıldı mı
evet
işte bunlar
setin
mapping
multi setin
multi mapping
aynı zamanda
dünya fonksiyonları
şimdi
sete geri dönelim
arkadaşlar
sette şöyle bir problem var
buraya çok dikkatli izleyelim
bazen
ekleme işlemi
yaptığım zaman
eklemenin
yapılıp yapılmadığını
bilmem gerekiyor
o yüzden
setin
buraya dikkat
insert fonksiyonu
normalde diğer
konteynerların
insert fonksiyonu
insert edilmiş
öğeye
iteratör
döndürüyordu
değil mi
hatırlıyor musunuz
insertteki konvensiyon
buydu
insert fonksiyonları
insert edilen
öğeye
iteratör
döndürür
eğer birden fazla
öğeye
insert ediyorsanız
insert edilen
ilk öğeye
iteratör
döndürüyordu
fakat şimdi
sette şöyle bir
problem var
sette
insert edilip
edilmediği
o değerin
yani anahtarın
sette olup
olmamasına
bağlı
o yüzden
setin
insert fonksiyonu
ilginç bir şekilde
yine
pair
döndürüyor
pair'in
kullanıldığı
çok tipik yerlerden biri
iteratör
all
pair'i
döndürüyor
buraya dikkat
eğer ekleme
yapılmışsa
insert fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri olan
pair'in
second'ı
true
bu
ve
pair'in
first'ü
yani iteratör olan
arkadaşlar
eklenmiş
öğeye
iteratör
eğer ekleme
eğer ekleme yapılmamış ise
bu durumda
pair'in
second'ı
false
arkadaşlar
pair'in
first'ü ise
zaten o değerden
var olduğu için
eklenmedi ya
var olan
öğeyinin
iteratör konumu
do the
lm
already
exists
anlaşıldı mı
hadi bir örnek yapalım
mesela bakınız
set'in
arkadaşlar
string açılımı
my set
print
my set
küçükten büyüğe ilişkisiyle sıralı şu anda
arkadaşlar
örneğin
buraya
efe'yi ekleyeceğim
insert fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
my set
insert
efe
tabi ben sette ne olduğunu sözde bilmiyorum
geri dönüş değerini
arkadaşlar bakın işte
otonun da faydasını görüyorsunuz
bakın oto olmasaydı
direk olay
şöyle yazmam gerekiyordu
stud pair'in
stud'ları da yazmıyorum
stud set'in
arkadaşlar
stud string
açılımının
iteratörü
virgül
boğul
geri dönüş değerini tutan nesne
örneği yazıcaktım
şimdi oto geldiğinde
doğrudan oto
ne diyelim
p
r
ama p r bir
nedir
arkadaşlar
pair
şimdi ekleme yapıldı mı
if
p r'nin
second'ı
takip edebiliyor muyuz
eğer ekleme yapılmışsa
second true
eğer ekleme yapılmamışsa
second false
bu arada
bazı arkadaşlarım diyor ki
size'a bakarak da anlayabilir miyim
tabi ki anlayabilirsiniz
yani ekleme yapılmışsa
size bir artacak
ekleme yapılmamışsa
size aynı değerde kalacak
daha iyi bir alternatif anlamında
söylemiyorum
işte ekleme yapılmış
see out
arkadaşlar
the new value
inserted
ama bakın
tabi ki
bu durumda
yıldız
p r'nin
first'ü
eklenmiş
ve y'ye
iteratör
else konumunda
see out
arkadaşlar
already
in the set
yıldız
yine
h r
nokta
first
gerçekten de
değerli
çalıştıralım
struc
bind
burada da
kullanabilirdik
evet zaten
hemen onu da
gösterecektim
o olsam
bravo
kesinlikle haklısınız
zaten ben olsam
struc
bind
kullanırdım
Ali Atacan
buraya new value
nereden geldi
şuraya yanlış yazmışım
evet
all
the new value
inserted
arkadaşlar
yıldız
p r
first
merset'in
insert'ü
evet
yanlış değilmiş
doğruymuş
the new value
inserted
efe
şuraya sadece
bir iki nokta
üstü
sefalan
koyalım ki
anlaşılsın
evet
hatta
parantez
kapa parantez
yine aynı şekilde
parantez
kapa parantez
add the new value
inserted
efe
bir de
konteynerımızı
yazdıralım
jprint
my set
son kez
çalıştırıyorum
evet
Ali Atacan
Eda
efe
ama şimdi
bu sefer
arkadaşlar
efe olsun
Eda
efe
evet
tekrar çalıştırıyorum
already in the set
efe
şimdi
tabii ki
structured binding
burada
çok daha kolay
bir yazım sağlıyor
structured binding
olsaydı
şöyle diyecektim
örneğin
auto
arkadaşlar
köşeli parantez
peerin
firstu için
iter
peerin
secondu için
inserted
eğer
boolean
değeri
duruysa
yıldız
iter
gördüğünüz gibi
simlendirme
daha
kolay hale
getirecekti
arkadaşlar
init listiyle
insert yaparsak
geri dönüş
değerinden
nasıl bilgiler
tutulacak
arkadaşlar
bu
sadece
tek bir
ö eklediğinizde
iteratör
boole pair'i
veriyor
anladınız
diğerleri böyle
değil
mesela
multi set'in de
Alihan
bir örnek vereyim
bakın bu set
oysa bu
multi set
olsaydı
multi set de
zaten
eklememe
ihtimali
olmadığı için
diğer
konteynerlarda
olduğu gibi
multi set'in
insert fonksiyonu
doğrudan
iteratör
döndürecekti
yani sadece
set'in
insert
fonksiyonu
böyle
evet
bir dahaki hafta
kaldığımız yerden
devam edeceğiz
derse katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
if
oysa
olsun
sonra
ne